voilà rebonsoir je tiens à accueillir
maintenant monsieur Jean-Bernard Lévy
dont le mandat de président
d'électricité de France vient tout juste
de se terminer et je tiens à remercier
d'avoir accepté de venir devant notre
commission d'enquête chargé d'établir
les raisons de la perte souveraineté
d'indépendance énergétique de la France
nous avons avant vous monsieur Levy eu
l'honneur d'auditionner monsieur
Gadonneix et pro-glio qui vous ont
précédé dans le même format d'audition
vous avez présidé après eux EDF pendant
huit années au cours de demande à
successifs de 2014 jusque au mois
dernier
la cessation ruissante de votre dernier
mandat ne dispense d'essayer de dresser
un tableau rétrospectif du contexte dans
lequel vous avez exercé vos mandats et
des activités du groupe vous avez en
effet été souvent entendu par les
organes du Parlement lors de l'examen de
texte législatif ou dans le cadre de
travaux d'évaluation et de contrôle
votre mandat n'en a pas moins été
traversé de grandes problématiques celle
du chantier de Flamanville du grand
carénage de la prolongation de la durée
de vie des centrales nucléaires la
sécurité des frictions nés des diverses
dispositions mises en place des
problèmes de corrosion sous contrainte
sur la fin de votre mandat
également déjà été abordés dans cette
enceinte ces problématiques
en incluant le rachat d'arriva et les
fermetures de réacteurs ceux de
Fessenheim mérite ici d'être examinés
sous l'angle retenu par notre commission
celui du processus décisionnel un
questionnaire vous a en ce sens c'était
envoyé par le rapporteur Monsieur
Antoine Armand je ne vais pas être plus
long que cela dans mon propos
introductif pour très vite vous laisser
la parole monsieur le Président tout en
nous excusant pour la demi-heure de
retard pour le début de l'audition et en
espérant que nous pourrons tous
collectivement voir la deuxième mi-temps
et c'est vrai qu'en fixant la date on
n'avait pas initialement anticiper la
qualification de l'équipe nationale de
football donc on va essayer de conjuguer
toutes ces toutes ces contraintes avant
de vous laisser la parole il me revient
de vous demander de bien vouloir prêter
serment en vertu de l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires
serment de dire la vérité toute la
vérité et rien que la vérité je vous
prie donc de bien vouloir lever la main
droite et dire je le jure
je le jure voilà je vous laisse la
parole pour un propos introductif merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les députés
d'abord je vous remercie de m'avoir
invité dans le cadre de votre enquête et
si vous le voulez bien comme convenu
avec le président et le rapporteur je
commencerai par un propos introductif
assez bref avant de répondre à vos
questions vous l'avez dit j'ai quitté
EDF il y a environ trois semaines et
donc les propos que je vais tenir sont
ceux d'un ancien dirigeant de notre
électricien national je ne suis plus
aujourd'hui qu'un observateur
indépendant un jeune retraité
bien sûr mon propos sera nourri par mon
expérience de huit années à la tête de
cette magnifique entreprise et je
voudrais saluer dès à présent
l'engagement des salariés d'EDF au
service de la collectivité nationale on
le voit jour après jour je voudrais
aussi vous dire que je ne traiterai que
d'électricité bien que EDF soit
également un fournisseur de gaz pour ses
clients qui sont déménagers et des
entreprises et les clients d'EDF pour le
gaz sont de plus en plus nombreux chaque
année chez un remercie un petit peu de
retour en arrière comme vous le savez
grâce au succès du programme
électro-nucléaire la France a pu engager
dès les années 80 la décarbonation de
son bouquet énergétique notamment grâce
au rôle joué par l'électricité dans le
chauffage des bâtiments
qui sont plus souvent chauffés à
l'électricité en France que dans les
pays comparables et de fait le poids de
l'électricité dans la consommation de
l'énergie la composition la consommation
totale de l'énergie est un peu plus
élevée en France qu'il ne l'est en
moyenne dans les pays voisins cela nous
donne sur tous nos voisins un net
avantage en matière de décarbonation
néanmoins les énergies d'origine fossile
en France celle qui produisent beaucoup
de dioxyde de carbone elle reste
largement majoritaire dans la
consommation d'énergie globale de notre
pays et chacun sait que notre territoire
ne recèle guerre de gisement en la
matière dès lors que la loi française
interdit d'aller ne serait-ce que
regarder ne serait-ce que regarder si
des pétroles ou des gaz de schistes
pourrait être exploités en France dans
des conditions attrayantes
pourrait dire qu'il est paradoxal que
suite à la guerre déclenchée par la
Russie sur le territoire
ukrainien nous nous mettons à importer
massivement et durablement du gaz
américain en provenance de formation
géologiques que nous nous interdisons
d'explorer et à fortiori d'exploiter en
France je vais peut-être un peu loin je
vais m'arrêter là sur ce sujet qui est
quand même à mes yeux le signal d'une
perte d'opportunité en matière de
souveraineté et d'indépendance
énergétique
je vais donc revenir à l'électricité qui
est depuis plus de 40 ans un atout
indéniable pour notre pays et pour notre
bilan carbone en grande partie grasse à
notre parc hydroélectrique mais aussi
bien sûr grâce à notre parc nucléaire
l'électricité bas carbone française
ainsi produite sur notre sol apporte au
pays un approvisionnement sur et
souverain il apporte de l'activité grâce
aux emplois industriels qui en découlent
il apporte des recettes commerciales
grâce aux exportations que nous pouvons
engranger et puis il apporte un
potentiel de compétitivité car le prix
de notre électricité devrait être
largement à l'abri des soubresauts des
prix des marchés des matières premières
on le sait tel n'est pas le cas on y
reviendra si vous le souhaitez
je voudrais dans un premier temps avant
de répondre à vos questions
m'attarder sur deux des causes qui me
semblent primordial dans l'analyse du
sujet de votre enquête quand j'arrive
chez EDF c'est fin 2014 qu'elle n'est
pas ma surprise de prendre conscience
des implications de la loi norme la loi
du 7 décembre 2010 qui institut un
mécanisme la reine l'accès régulé à
l'électricité nucléaire historique la
mécanisme pernicieux qui va croissant
sur l'endettement d'EDF au rythme
d'environ 3 à 4 milliards d'euros chaque
année d'accroissement de l'endettement
d'EDF je l'ai dit répéter pendant 8 ans
la reine est un poison pour EDF et je
voudrais expliciter avec vous les trois
raisons qui font de la reine un poison
tout d'abord le prix le prix est de 42
euros pour un mégawh il est inchangé
depuis l'instauration de l'arène le 1er
janvier 2011 et j'observe que ce prix
s'appliquera encore sur l'exercice 2023
ce prix est manifestement sous-évalué
par rapport au prix de revient de notre
production nucléaire je me réfère par
exemple au calcul détaillé qui ont été
produits en 2019 par la creux la
Commission de régulation de l'énergie
pourtant elle est peu suspecte de
soutien à l'égard de DF cette
sous-évaluation engendre un
affaiblissement systématique d'EDF et je
vais y revenir mais je voudrais d'abord
vous dire qu'au moment même de mon
arrivée en 2014 devant cette
sous-évaluation manifeste le
gouvernement français et la Commission
européenne avait engagé des discussions
approfondi pour augmenter la valeur de
l'arène faire passer la valeur d'un
mégawattheure d'arène de 42 à 52 euros
par pallier de 2 euros chaque année
et là cette négociation a pris fin assez
vite lorsque le prix du mégawattheure
sur le marché de gros européen est tombé
sous les 42 euros c'était dans les
derniers mois de 2015 et nous en sommes
depuis rester à 42 euros et lorsque le
prix de gros tombe sous les 42 euros
comme fin 2015 et en 2016 nous voyons
naturellement les opérateurs
concurrentes d'EDF dédaigner tout achat
à la reine pour acheter sur le marché à
un prix inférieur et en cela EDF est en
somme une deuxième fois victime de la
reine puisque ce mécanisme revient à
donner une option gratuite aux
concurrent d'EDF dont bien évidemment
ses concurrents font usage qu'on
opportunité se présente cette
caractéristique tout à fait étonnante et
décrite par le mot asymétrie
EDF se retrouve donc en 2016 et 2017
avec des recettes très inférieures
puisque le prix de gros du mégawattheure
tombe à 30 euros et même par moment sous
les 30 euros jusqu'à 26 euros
ce manque à gagner contre EDF à un plan
de restructuration sévère qui est de
fait imposer par les agences de notation
qui dégradent à trois reprises la dette
de DF ce plan a été approuvé et rendu
public en avril 2016 il comprenait un
ensemble important de cessions d'actifs
une trajectoire d'économie sur les coûts
de fonctionnement et une concentration
des investissements d'EDF sur les
activités bas carbone déjà
ces trois aspects ces trois volets du
plan ont été mises en œuvre par EDF
conformément aux objectifs d'origine
le plan a été préparé et réalisé avec un
soutien remarquable du ministère de
l'économie et des pouvoirs publics en
général car l'État pour la première fois
Renault au dividendes d'EDF payé cash
les talignent que cela va durer pendant
des années et il est à souscrit de plus
à hauteur de 3 milliards d'euros à une
augmentation de capital 4 milliards
d'euros au total qui sera mise en place
tout début 2017
je voudrais souligner que c'est la
première fois depuis longtemps peut-être
même depuis la création d'EDF en 1946
c'est la première fois que le
contribuable vient sortir l'entreprise
nationale d'une situation créée par une
mauvaise loi car il faut rappeler que le
parc de production d'EDF ainsi que les
réseaux d'enedis et de RTI ont été
intégralement financés par l'entreprise
et donc de fait par ses clients mais pas
par les contribuables donc pas par
l'État
il est vrai que l'établissement public
EDF jusqu'au début des années 2000
bénéficiait de la garantie de l'État et
empruntait à moindre coût c'était avant
la mise en œuvre des directives
européennes d'ouverture des marchés de
l'énergie mais enfin je le dis c'est la
première fois et ces cinq ans après
l'instauration de la reine que le
contribuable vient secourir EDF
la troisième raison qui pénalise EDF au
titre de la reine c'est le simple fait
que les concurrents d'EDF n'ont plus à
se préoccuper d'investissement physique
en matière de production d'électricité
je mets de côté les renouvelables qui
font l'objet de prix garanti il suffit à
ces opérateurs alternatifs de d'acheter
de l'électricité au guichet de la reine
ils ne prennent aucun risque
d'investisseurs aucun risque
d'exploitant tous les risques sont
portés par EDF
des concurrents de EDF la reine fait des
rentiers
et quand ses concurrents se trompent sur
le besoin leurs besoins ça a été le cas
en 2022 il suspendre leurs offres
commerciales il cessent de proposer
leurs services certains même déposent le
bilan et les risques sont à nouveau
transférés sur EDF une manœuvre qui sur
2022 et 2023 aura coûté plusieurs
milliards d'euros à EDF
depuis plus de 10 ans cette régulation
de la reine favorable ou fournisseur
alternatif ne les a donc pas incité à
créer des capacités de production propre
la reine a donc été un frein au
développement d'une capacité énergétique
souveraine sur notre sol par les
opérateurs alternatifs voici donc les
trois raisons qui font de la loi nomme
et de la reine qui en est issus une
cause profonde et durable de
l'affaiblissement d'EDF bien sûr un EDF
affaibli n'est pas en mesure de
développer sereinement son activité au
bénéfice de la collectivité nationale
au cours des huit années durant
lesquelles j'ai eu l'honneur de présider
EDF une bonne partie de l'énergie de la
direction générale de l'entreprise a été
absorbée par la nécessité absolue
d'obtenir une réforme de la régulation
qui pesait et pèse encore aujourd'hui
lourdement sur l'entreprise je me
réjouis de voir qu'aujourd'hui la
question de la souveraineté énergétique
du soutien aux investissements sur nos
territoires sont enfin
identifiés au niveau européen
identifié par résolu mais Identifier
c'est déjà ça
le deuxième thème que je voudrais
aborder dans ce propos liminaire c'est
celui de la fixation des priorités en
matière de mix électrique de quoi
parle-t-on on parle des besoins en
électricité des besoins pour le
chauffage la mobilité l'industrie pour
satisfaire quel niveau de demande quelle
part dans la production doit-on viser
pour les énergies nouvelles
renouvelables faut-il arrêter des moyens
de production fossile faut-il en
construire de nouveau faut-il arrêter
décentrales nucléaires faut-il en
construire de nouvelles faut-il peut-on
augmenter significativement la
production hydroélectricité et dans
quelles conditions doit-on prévoir des
moyens significatifs de stockage de
l'électricité quel rôle donnait aux
importations pour assurer la sécurité
d'approvisionnement aux heures de pointe
voilà un ensemble de questions qui se
posent et sur lesquelles je voudrais
être très clair parce que lorsqu'on
dirige EDF ou qu'on travaille au sein
d'EDF il n'est à aucun moment question
de se à la volonté démocratique telle ce
qu'elle s'exprime par des directives
européennes des lois françaises des
décrets ou tout autre réglementation
bien évidemment et comme toute partie
prenante au système électrique EDF
partage ses analyses et tentent de faire
prévaloir son point de vue auprès des
décideurs politiques et des régulateurs
à Paris comme à Bruxelles chaque fois
que l'État ou le régulateur met des
projets de cette nature en consultation
EDF produit et rend public une
contribution détaillée établie sur des
bases rationnelles
bien évidemment EDF s'attend à ce que
l'État respecte les lois et règlements
qui la lui-même fait voter ou qu'il a
établi et en tant que personne morale
EDF peut demander au tribunaux de juger
s'il y a préjudice du fait d'une
application contestable et contestée des
textes bien évidemment avec les marges
de manœuvre qui sont les siennes la
direction générale de déesse tente de
négocier les meilleures conditions
d'application de ces textes afin de
préserver l'intérêt social de
l'entreprise et de ses actionnaires
notamment les actionnaires minoritaires
mais qui pourrait croire à l'instant que
des f n'a d'autre boussole que
l'application des obligations que lui
crée le code de l'énergie cela est vrai
en France bien sûr mais aussi dans tous
les pays où EDF opère
de ce fait EDF vit au rythme des
décisions de politique énergétiques et
électriques qui sont prises par les
gouvernements élus démocratiquement dans
notre pays et EDF s'attache à répondre
aux objectifs que lui fixe l'État dans
son double rôle d'actionnaire et de
régulateur
n'est pas ici difficile de s'interroger
on va sûrement y revenir donc je le fais
volontiers devant vous sur la cohérence
la cohérence entre le temps long des
projets industriels et le temps
nettement plus court du calendrier
électoral est souvent de l'alternance
politique à cet égard je pense que
l'exercice mené par RTE à l'occasion de
la description des différents futurs
énergétiques possibles à l'horizon 2050
je crois que cet exercice a marqué un
tournant bienvenu dans la capacité de
notre pays à se projeter dans le temps
long en partant d'une analyse
rationnelle et communiquée aux acteurs
mais cela ne veut pas dire que DF a eu
la même analyse ou la même appréciation
que RTE sur tous les aspects du dossier
pour tout acteur industriels pour toute
entreprise attachée à prendre des
décisions rationnelles qui l'engage à
long terme agir sur la base d'une
décision politique elle-même fondée sur
une approche technique et économique
sérieuse cela est indispensable et on
sait que DFI compris dans la période
récente n'a pas toujours vécu dans cette
situation
s'agissant du nucléaire qui est en
France est dans bien d'autres pays fait
l'objet de polémique depuis des
décennies on voit bien aujourd'hui les
difficultés où nous a conduit cette
nécessaire c'est indispensable
subordination de l'entreprise aux
décisions politiques
à mes yeux de citoyens cette hiérarchie
est et reste souhaitable même si on voit
bien les risques induits les dépenses
inutiles les difficultés à motiver ou à
embaucher les salariés dans la filière
à titre de conclusion pour ce propos
introductif je voudrais plaider avec
toute la conviction dont je suis capable
je voudrais plaider pour une vision
stratégique cohérente et stable dans les
décisions de politique énergétiques et
en conséquence dans les décisions sur le
mix électrique et sur les meilleurs
usages de l'électricité
la situation actuelle démontre une
tension inattendue sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement une tension
inattendue sur les prix depuis de
nombreux mois et des retards là si on
parle d'années des retards peu
explicables dans les engagements
climatiques pris par notre pays et la
contestation est générale qui ne
conteste telle ou telle décision prise
il y a deux ans pris il y a 5 ans il y a
10 ans où il y a 15 ans
à mes yeux le moment est venu de la
clarification des objectifs énergétiques
que la collectivité nationale se donne
sur le long terme mais pas seulement sur
une période de 5 ans cette clarification
je souhaiterais qu'elle soit basée sur
les fêtes dans un domaine où fleurissent
les fake news
qu'elle soit basée sur des objectifs
programmatiques précis sur le long terme
car les infrastructures énergétiques ne
se construisent pas sans une approche de
long terme et sans ténacité
alors nous avons aujourd'hui la chance
de disposer pour la planète d'une
feuille de route pour les 30 années qui
viennent c'est l'accord de Paris nous
avons l'engagement de notre propre pays
d'atteindre la neutralité carbone en
2050 et puis en toute modestie nous
avons aussi la raison d'être d'EDF qui
vise à concilier préservation de la
planète bien-être et développement et
justement parce que nous sommes en crise
aujourd'hui en France et en Europe je
crois que les conditions peuvent être
remplies pour changer dès maintenant le
mode de fonctionnement trop incertain de
notre planification je formule le voeu
contre l'on puisse revenir au programme
de long terme ceux qui ont permis
l'électrification dans les années 50
l'accompagnement des trentes glorieuses
jusqu'aux années 70 et le choix
stratégique du nucléaire un choix
constant des années 60 jusqu'à la fin
des années 80 avec l'accélération qui
avait été induite par la crise
pétrolière de 1973
et je suis maintenant à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions
merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président pour
ces éléments de contexte
j'aurais plusieurs questions une
première qui revient sur sur la reine
que vous avez longuement développé
pourquoi il n'y a-t-il pas eu de votre
point de vue de revalorisation de son
prix alors que il semblerait que cela
était prévu initialement dans la loi
norme et quel articulation au niveau
européen s'est construite entre la
discussion sur le prix de la reine et
la nature de des concessions
hydroélectriques
je crois je crois monsieur le Président
avoir un peu un peu répondu à cette à
cette première question dans mon dans
mon propos quand je suis arrivé il y
avait consensus au sein du gouvernement
pour porter près de la Commission
européenne une demande d'augmentation de
la reine par palier de 2 € 42 44 en
montant à 52 euros
ceci n'était pas lié de façon formelle à
quelques avancée que ce soit en matière
de concession hydroélectrique c'était un
dossier que le l'administration le
gouvernement français
justifiait de par la nature des coûts de
notre
parc nucléaire et EDF n'avait pas à
prendre parti sur
quelconque compromis entre le dossier
des concessions hydroélectriques et une
augmentation du prix de la reine
l'augmentation du prix de la reine
allait aller de soi simplement comme je
l'ai dit dans mon propos introductif
elle ne sait pas faite
ce que le prix de gros sur le marché est
descendu sous 42 puis sous 35 puissent
ou 30 et qu'à ce moment là la Commission
a estimé qu'il était bien naturel de
laisser le marché fonctionner et si le
marché disait que l'électricité valait
28 ou 37 en tout cas sous les 42 il n'y
avait pas matière à passer de 42 à 52 le
volume de la reine puisque nos
concurrents achetaient sur le marché
n'achetez pas au volume de la reine et
donc la porte s'est fermée c'est
refermée sur ce dossier je dirais dans
le courant de l'année 2016
merci beaucoup
dans nos précédentes auditions on a
auditionné les responsables successifs
du CEA et avec Monsieur Jacques
on a découvert la proposition la façon
dont l'arbitrage sur l'abandon du
programme Astrid du CES construit et il
prétend que
l'abandon de ce programme c'est fait en
concertation avec notamment EDF et
Orano est-ce que vous pouvez confirmer
ces propos
le le
inutile de vous dire que EDF est
extrêmement attaché à ce que notre pays
mette en place des solutions
dit de sur Générer de surgénérateur
régénérateur doivent manières à fermer
le cycle et faire en sorte que la
production de déchets soit nulle ou
totalement minime de déchets nucléaires
et donc il n'y a aucun doute que la
maison que j'ai dirigée portait en elle
la volonté de trouver des solutions
technologiques
portaient en elle le regret de la
fermeture de super Phénix il y a
maintenant 25 ans
et portait en elle le souhait de
construire les avec le CEA notamment qui
est en charge des technologies
nucléaires avancées de construire des
solutions permettant de répondre à cette
question en revanche il n'est pas faute
de dire que
les ingénieurs des DF avec lesquels je
parlais estimait qu'autant le programme
Astrid était justifié dans sa dimension
de recherche de technologie de
développement de nos solutions
idoine pour gérer peut-être mieux que ne
l'avait fait super Phénix les
difficultés techniques rencontrées avec
notamment avec le sodium comme calories
porteur autant il y avait chez EDF au
temps où je le dirigeais et autant le
programme Astrid était financé un
certain scepticisme quant à l'idée qu'on
allait passer directement d'une
démonstration technologique sur ce que
pourrait être à nouveau réacteur à la
construction immédiate de ce réacteur et
donc il y avait deux volets dans le
programme Astrid tel que je l'ai perçu
un volet technologique que DF soutenait
entièrement et un volet de démonstrateur
de mémoire de 600 mégawatts mais ma
mémoire me peut me tromper donc
on peut me faire défaut un démonstrateur
directement connecté sur le réseau qui
est peut-être une anticipation de la du
fait qu'on allait trouver une solution
alors qu'il fallait peut-être d'abord
démontrer que la solution existait et
donc voilà la réponse que je peux vous
faire maintenant la décision d'arrêter
le programme Astrid n'a pas été prise
ma connaissance dans un cercle ou EDF
était présent en tout cas je n'étais pas
personnellement présent je pense que
cette décision n'a pas été prise en
présence d'un quelconque représentant
d'EDF en séance
merci
actuellement le système français est
confronté au défi de du problème
générique de la corrosion sous
contrainte comment au sein d'EDF
ce risque du problème générique sur le
parc nucléaire était-il anticipé et
comment on été traités les alertes
successives de l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire quant à la disparition
progressive des marges de de production
d'énergie pilotable à disposition qui
risquait de mettre en arbitrage sécurité
d'approvisionnement et sûreté
d'exploitation nucléaire
je vais d'abord peut-être répondre à la
toute fin nous nous arbitrons pas la
sécurité d'approvisionnement et où la
sûreté nucléaire nous nous avons comme
principe absolu de mettre en avant avant
tout la sûreté nucléaire pour deux
raisons la première c'est que le respect
des règles de sûreté nucléaire nous
semble intrinsèquement lié à la
confiance qu'on les Français dans cette
énergie
électro-nucléaire et la deuxième c'est
que nous ne sommes pas chargés de la
sécurité d'approvisionnement donc nous
ne pourrions pas faire un arbitrage
entre quelque chose dont nous sommes
directement responsables le
fonctionnement en toute sûreté de nos
réacteurs selon les prescriptions de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire quelque
chose dont nous ne sommes pas
responsables qui est la sécurité
d'approvisionnement puisque nous sommes
devenus depuis maintenant assez
longtemps un opérateur le plus important
des opérateurs mais seulement un
opérateur et l'équilibre comme vous le
savez bien est assuré
l'équilibre offre de monde est assuré
par la liberté maintenant en ce qui
concerne le problème
rencontré sur la corrosion sous
contrainte vous l'avez dit c'est le mot
que vous avez employé c'est un problème
générique dans une
ignorons tout de l'ampleur au moment où
il est découvert et nous ignorons même
quelques semaines avant qu'il soit
découvert qu'on va avoir un problème
générique et donc le problème n'est sur
les le premier puis assez rapidement sur
quatre réacteurs de la catégorie dite N4
ceux qui sont à 1450 MW de puissance et
puis assez rapidement on s'aperçoit
qu'il y a des présomptions de corrosion
sous contrainte sur des réacteurs de la
catégorie 1300 mégawatts et on va
effectivement trouver de la corrosion
sous contrainte sur certains de ces
réacteurs en revanche on a assez
rapidement enfin quelques mois après vu
que les réacteurs à 900 mégawatts les
premiers qui ont été construits les plus
anciens sont à l'abri de ce sujet ce qui
montre bien d'ailleurs que ce sujet
n'est pas un problème de vieillissement
mais un problème de gestion technique de
pratiques techniques en matière de
soudure sur les réacteurs de 1450
mégawatts qui sont les plus récents qui
rencontrent le problème alors que les
plus anciens pour simplifier ne leur
rencontre pas ou pratiquement ou
pratiquement pas donc la question de la
marge de manœuvre est évidemment une
question tout à fait tout à fait
essentielle
il est tout à fait exact que avec la
fermeture de nombre de
le réacteur utilisant des énergies
fossiles quand je suis arrivé chez EDF
il y avait encore des réacteurs
fonctionnent au fioul et puis il y avait
davantage de centrales également au
charbon les marges de manœuvre de ce qui
est pilotable ont été réduites
néanmoins
RTE qui en est qui en est chargé ne
s'est pas inscrit contre la fermeture de
ces centrales fossiles pilotables ce qui
fait que oui de toute évidence quand le
problème générique est arrivé il est
malheureusement arrivé fin 2021 et
compte tenu de l'ampleur de ce de ce
problème générique on s'est retrouvé
avec une production fragilisée et une
mise à risque de l'équilibre offre
demande pour l'instant on a bien vu que
la demande des
et satisfaite par l'offre mais chacun
sait que on est aujourd'hui dans un dans
un hiver plus difficile que les hivers
précédents
c'est sous votre mandat que la centrale
nucléaire de Fessenheim a été arrêtée
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire deux
mots comme à la façon dont vous avez
accès
monsieur
méritait que je que je prépare une
réponse circonstanciée si vous le
permettez
voilà donc en effet la fermeture
définitive des deux réacteurs 900
mégawatts de Fessenheim d'être du
premier semestre 2020 ce qui correspond
à la période
où les deux réacteurs ont atteint les 40
années de fonctionnement je voudrais
rappeler que dans les années qui
précédaient le faire leur fermeture les
deux réacteurs de Fessenheim étaient
jugés par l'autorité sûreté nucléaire
comme appliquant de manière tout à fait
conforme les règles de sûreté ils
étaient jugés parmi les meilleurs du
parc nucléaire français
l'arrêt des réacteurs fait manifestement
suite à une campagne de dénigrement
permanente et ancienne venant des
organisations non gouvernementales
anti-nucléaires basées en France et
surtout en Allemagne et également un
ensemble de décisions de politique
énergétique que je voudrais résumer
comme suit
le je cite délégué interministériel à
l'avenir du territoire de Fessenheim
délégué ministériel à l'avenir du
territoire de Fessenheim a été institué
par un décret du 11 décembre 2012 il est
chargé c'est le texte du décret que j'ai
compulsé sur Internet il est chargé de
préparer et coordonnées les opérations
nécessaires à la fermeture de la
centrale nucléaire de Fessenheim
la loi de transition énergétique pour la
croissance verte du 17 août 2015
plafonne à 63,2 gigawatts la capacité de
production nucléaire en France cette loi
en pratique ne me permet pas la mise en
service de l'EPR de Flamanville sans la
déconnexion définitive d'une capacité
nucléaire équivalente qui correspond à
peu près à deux réacteurs de 900 MW par
décision du 13 août 2015 le Conseil
constitutionnel rappelle le droit d'EDF
à indemnisation par l'État au titre du
préjudice subi du fait de l'application
du plafonnement
en application ces lois dérèglements EDF
exclut les deux réacteurs de Fessenheim
du périmètre qui fait l'objet du projet
dit vd4 900 ce qui veut dire visite
décennales numéro 4 quatrième visite au
moment des 40 ans vd4900 du programme
grand carénage ce programme ayant
lui-même été autorisé par le conseil
d'administration de DF sous mon
initiative en janvier 2015 au deuxième
semestre 2015 la fermeture des deux
réacteurs devient donc inéluctable il va
de soi que le président directeur
général d'EDF en tant que mandataire
social de l'entreprise aurait commis une
faute de gestion si EDF avait poursuivi
les travaux pour prolonger la durée de
vie des réacteurs de Fessenheim en
ignorant dans la loi de 2015 que le
décret de 2012
les négociations entre DF et l'État sur
le protocole d'indemnisation ont démarré
en avril 2016 elles ont été ralenties à
cause notamment du retard pris par la
construction du réacteur européen de
Flamanville qui conduit à désynchroniser
la fermeture de Fessenheim de la mise en
service de Flamanville Fessenheim va
donc aller jusqu'à 40 ans
pour formuler un avis indépendant sur le
protocole le conseil d'administration
d'EDF s'organise sous la forme d'un
groupe de travail Haddock qui se réunit
de très nombreuses fois le protocole est
également amendé suite aux observations
de la Commission européenne et à celles
du Comité ministériel des transactions
au sein du ministère de la transition
écologique et solidaire au fil des
négociations et des observations le
conseil d'administration d'EDF a
approuvé quatre délibérations relatives
à ce protocole d'indemnisation
protocole a été signé par la ministre de
la transition écologique et solidaire et
par le président directeur général d'EDF
le 27 septembre 2019 le 30 septembre
2019 EDF a adressé la demande
d'abrogation de l'autorisation
d'exploiter la centrale de Fessenheim
qui a fait l'objet du décret du 18
février 2020
je voudrais également rappeler qu'un
premier décret portant sur la progresse
l'abrogation de l'autorisation
d'exploiter la centrale de Fessenheim
daté du 8 avril 2017
avait été annulé par le Conseil d'État
en octobre 2018
monsieur le président
et qu'elle appréciation portez-vous du
coup sur
cette fermeture que DF a appliqué la loi
merci
[Musique]
pas voter en faveur de la construction
des deux réacteurs d'inklepoint le
dossier d'inklepoint avait une dimension
industrielle et certainement aussi une
dimension une dimension économique et
puis également une dimension de
financement
peut-être
l'industrie puis l'économique puis le
financement ce qui concerne la dimension
industrielle il est apparu au président
que j'étais qu'il était extrêmement
important de consolider à l'époque je
rappelle
c'est avant le brexit juste avant
d'ailleurs le vote du brexit qui date de
l'été 2016 et là nous sommes au mars
avril 2016 il était important de
consolider le soutien de
la Grande-Bretagne qui s'exprimait déjà
depuis une bonne dizaine d'années à
travers plusieurs gouvernements
travaillistes et également plusieurs
gouvernements conservateurs le soutien
de la Grande-Bretagne au nucléaire la
France n'est pas isolée en Europe mais
elle n'est pas majoritaire en faveur du
nucléaire et le soutien de la
Grande-Bretagne non seulement au
nucléaire pour assurer la décarbonation
mais aussi à l'industrie française
puisque DF est le seul exploitant de
centrales nucléaires en France en
Grande-Bretagne par en France aussi mais
en Grande-Bretagne aussi et que le
gouvernement britannique a retenu
technologie française la technologie de
l'EPR pour la construction de deux et on
espère bientôt d'ailleurs de 4 réacteurs
EPR et donc la dimension industrielle
est très importante c'est un soutien
britannique un grand pays un pays de
haute technologie à une technologie
française c'est aussi évidemment un
signe important un signal important qui
est donné à tous les pays dans le monde
qui s'interrogent sur LEPR et
Flamanville est déjà en retard et qui
voit qu'un pays totalement indépendant
prend une décision en faveur de l'EPR
alors qu'il y ait on le sait extrêmement
critiqué sur notre propre territoire et
donc sur le plan industriel j'ajoute que
c'est un plan de charge important pour
les usines françaises à la fois les
bureaux d'études dans lesquels il y a
des milliers d'ingénieurs qui vont
travailler et qui travaillent encore
aujourd'hui sur inklley point et puis
sur les usines dans lesquelles de très
nombreuses fabrication chez Framatome
chez Ji à Belfort mais aussi dans chez
bien d'autres sous-traitants saison 2 ou
de rang 3 et donc ça va alimenter des
usines de fabrication qui si vous me
permettez les l'expression non pas
beaucoup de plancha compte tenues que
Flamanville est là mais qui a rien
derrière flamant ville si vous me
permettez l'expression donc sur le plan
industriel il me semble que le dossier
fait
vraiment consensus sur le plan
économique mon prédécesseur a négocié
une un mode de un mode de financement
avec ce qu'on appelle un contrat pour
différence qui permet d'assurer dans la
plupart des cas une belle rentabilité à
l'investisseur que vont être le le
partenaire chinois qui s'appelle CGN qui
est toujours présent bien sûr au capital
de la société qui construit et qui
exploitera les deux réacteurs et puis à
EDF le contrat pour différents est à un
prix qui est un peu critiqué en
Grande-Bretagne par la Cour des comptes
en disant que c'est quand même un peu
généreux mais qui donc vue de France
finalement n'est pas si mauvais et puis
c'est un prix pour parler de la reine
tout à l'heure mais c'est le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés c'est
un prix qui est indexé sur l'inflation
et donc aujourd'hui nous avons largement
construit une époint avec des livres et
des euros des années précédentes tu t'es
pas terminé mais on en est à mettons
60%. on va bénéficier des 10%
d'inflation qu'on vit aujourd'hui en
Grande-Bretagne et donc la rentabilité
économique de linkleboint elle est un
petit peu érodée par les retards que
nous avons rencontrés qui ne sont pas
considérables mais elle reste
d'excellentes factures donc sur le plan
industriel pour moi c'est une évidence
qu'il faut le faire sur le plan
économique à l'époque et encore
aujourd'hui je peux vous confirmer que
c'est une affaire qui est atteint un
niveau de rentabilité tout à fait
convenable ensuite il y a la question du
financement et en effet la question du
financement est délicate puisque quand
je suis arrivé on m'a dit on m'a dit
qu'on cherchait un financement
permettant de déconsolider inkipoint
c'est-à-dire de faire porter le
financement en capital par un ensemble
d'investisseurs dont EDF ne serait
qu'une part minoritaire et puis par un
ensemble de
prêteurs qui permettraient sur la base
du contrat pour différence d'assurer
l'économie complète du projet il ne m'a
fallu que quelque semaines pour ma
percevoir que ce qui m'était présenté
par l'équipe précédente et permettez-moi
de dire que le directeur financier qui
est parti en faisait partie de cette
équipe que celle-ci n'était pas fondée
sur de véritables engagements de
quelques parties au capital que ce soit
en dehors du partenaire chinois c'est
d'ailleurs moi-même qui est négocié le
chiffre de 33% 33,5% qui est aujourd'hui
la contribution du partenaire du
partenaire chinois et donc le projet qui
fait beaucoup de sens sur le plan
industriel et sur le plan économique
rencontre des difficultés de financement
puisque le principe même du financement
d'inkley point qui m'a été présenté
lorsque j'arrive fin 2014 au bout de
quelques semaines ou quelques mois je
m'aperçois qu'il est irréaliste et qu'il
ne pourra pas se produire et la question
se pose à ce moment-là bien sûr avec
l'État en tant qu'actionnaire doit-on
assurer le financement au sein d'EDF ou
bien abandonne-t-on le projet et il est
clair que pour les deux tiers de ce
financement et eDF va porter un
endettement qui est assez important
pendant de nombreuses années en
attendant là les recettes que des f va
pouvoir trouver lorsque les réacteurs
seront mis en service le débat avec
l'État a lieu il a lieu avec l'Agence
des participations de l'État il a lieu
avec les responsables ministériels
concernés et la conclusion de ce débat
c'est que l'État souhaite que le projet
inklle pas une se fasse et il va voter
en faveur du projet inclipoint au sein
du conseil d'administration d'ailleurs
c'est une l'avait pas voté vous imaginez
bien que le projet ne serait ne se
serait pas
construit du tout et donc je dirais
rétrospectivement je crois que c'est une
décision qui était tout à fait
indispensable elle a été soutenue par
l'État sur le plan le poids difficile
qui était le point du du financement et
amené à l'industrie nucléaire française
EDF Framatome J et bien d'autres un plan
de charge bienvenu elle donnera
d'ailleurs aussi demain à Orano du
travail et puis sur le plan économique
c'était une affaire tout à fait tout à
fait convenable et ça allait rester donc
si je puis dire je persiste les signes
qu'il fallait prendre cette décision qui
a été prise en toute connaissance de
cause au sein du conseil
d'administration d'EDF j'ai une toute
dernière question avant de passer la
parole aux rapporteur vous disiez dans
votre propos introductif ne pas
forcément toujours avoir la même analyse
que RTE sur les les scénarios sur les
projections
[Musique]
quels sont ces points de différence je
vais je vais m'attarder sur un point qui
est le plus important qui n'est pas le
seul et qui est le plus important qui
s'agit des des sur le plan prospectif
des besoins en électricité ce qu'on
appelle la demande rTE est chargée par
le gouvernement je le dis je le
rappelais de
conduire une étude prospective servant à
éclairer les décisions du gouvernement
en matière d'électricité et
à mes yeux et c'est un sujet que
à mes yeux et c'est un sujet que j'ai
beaucoup travaillé les scénarios de RTE
prospectif à l'horizon 2050 reste
inspiré par une approche que j'estime un
peu ancienne qui découle notamment des
conséquences de ce qu'on a observé
depuis 20 ans c'est-à-dire la
désindustrialisation de notre pays qui
conduit est-ce qu'il y a moins d'usines
et donc moins d'électricité nécessaire
dans les dans les usines or aujourd'hui
la priorité est donnée d'une part à la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
qui passe par l'électricité décarbonée
pour se substituer dans bien des
domaines à l'énergie fossile et d'autre
part à la reconquête de notre
souveraineté industrielle et énergétique
ce que prévoit RTE sur les 30 prochaines
années c'est une croissance que je
qualifie de modeste de la consommation
de l'électricité en volume de l'ordre de
1% par an un peu moins de 1% par an
dans le scénario central de RTE alors
que je vais y revenir nombreux sont les
facteurs qui pourraient amener à
considérer comme plus vraisemblable une
croissance en volume de la consommation
d'électricité en France qui serait entre
1,5 et 2% par an
chaque année pendant 30 ans parmi ces
facteurs on peut citer la démographie la
population de notre pays sacroît on peut
citer l'accroissement du nombre de
logements à population constante il y a
de moins en moins de personnes par
logement on peut citer genre j'en disais
un mot tout à l'heure la
réindustrialisation et l'effort de
contrôle de notre souveraineté
énergétique on peut citer la
numérisation de la Société des mesures
sectorielles très fortes telles que
l'arrêt de la vente de véhicules
thermiques 9 pour les particuliers dès
2035 on peut citer les besoins en
hydrogène des carbonées notamment dans
l'industrie on peut citer la nouvelle
réglementation thermique sur les
logements qui enfin
privilégie l'électricité des carbonées
plutôt que le gaz au moins pour les
logements neufs on peut citer je vais
m'arrêter là la substitution de four
électrique à des fours au gaz naturel
dans nombre de procédés industriels
et cette importance facteurs de
croissance de la demande en électricité
pour les prochaines années vont certes
être tempérés par des efforts de
sobriété et d'efficacité énergétique
mais le rapport de RTE dans ce domaine
ou combien important de la sobriété et
de l'efficacité énergétique ce
rapportable sur des résultats nettement
meilleurs chaque année d'ici à 2050 que
tout ce qui a été observé en France ou
dans des pays comparables depuis 30 ans
il me semble donc une stratégie
énergétique nationale se basant pour une
fourchette de consommation domestique
annuel d'électricité de 750 à 800
terwattheure en 2050 ferait courir
nettement moins de risques à notre pays
que le point moyen de 645 terawattheure
qui a été retenu en 2000 fin 2021 et
2021 et début 2022 voilà la réponse que
je voulais donner à votre question
monsieur le Président merci beaucoup
monsieur le rapporteur
et alors par contre il faudra couper
votre micro le rapporteur peut pas
parler en même temps merci monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur Lévy pour ces
premières réponses également pour les
réponses que vous nous avez communiqué
en amont de cet entretien première
question très simple en tant qu'ensein
président de DF est-ce que vous êtes
surpris par la situation énergétique
actuelle
on est toujours surpris quand la crise
arrive
on est en situation de crise énergétique
bien avant la guerre en Ukraine le prix
du du gaz a commencé à monter en flèche
la plupart des observateurs considèrent
que c'est une question d'équilibre entre
l'offre et la demande liée ou rebond
très fort à l'époque de l'économie
chinoise qui a fait monter les prix du
gaz les prix du GNL de façon très
importante et puis cela bien sûr a été
amplifié par la guerre en Ukraine et on
a vu les prix du gaz et les prix de
l'électricité augmentée de façon tout à
fait considérable l'été dernier et puis
se repositionner depuis quelques
semaines à des niveaux qui restent
nettement plus élevés que les niveaux
qui avaient été rencontrés c'est ces
années précédentes donc on est toujours
surpris quand la crise arrive parce que
qui ne peut pas être surpris du rebond
de l'économie chinoise après le
ralentissement du covid qui d'ailleurs
ne peut pas être surpris par le covid
qui ne peut pas être surpris par
l'invasion du crâne etc etc ce qui me
paraît important au-delà de la au-delà
de la surprise c'est souligner
l'impréparation dans laquelle est
l'Europe la préparation dans laquelle et
l'Europe parce que l'Europe a voulu
compter essentiellement sur le marché
pour réguler les marchés de l'énergie et
on voit bien aujourd'hui que le marché
est important mais qu'il n'a pas réponse
à tout et que c'est un préparation se
traduit alors c'est vrai en France un
peu plus du fait de la corrosion sous
contrainte sur le réacteur nucléaire
mais c'est vrai dans nombre de pays
d'Europe se traduit aujourd'hui par une
très grande fragilité des systèmes
énergétiques on le voit en ce qui
concerne la provisionnement en gaz et on
le voit aussi en ce qui concerne
l'électricité il n'y a pas que la France
la Grande-Bretagne l'Italie et la
Belgique les Pays-Bas bien d'autres pays
se préoccupent aujourd'hui de
l'équilibre offre demande en matière
d'électricité donc oui
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire le
problème est un peu plus aigu en France
sur l'électricité du fait de la
corrosion sous contrainte des réacteurs
nucléaires mais il est quand même d'une
grande acuité sur l'électricité chez
nombre de nos voisins et puis il est
extrêmement aigu aussi sur
merci
vous arrivez à la tête de DF fin 2014 on
peut imaginer que vous avez un entretien
au moins de courtoisie peut-être même
d'orientation générale avec le goût de
l'élément du gouvernement peut-être la
ministre ou le ministre en charge de
l'énergie est-ce que c'est le cas
la manière dont a été conduit mon
passage de Thalès à
EDF a été extrêmement rapide
je n'ai que quelques heures pour donner
une réponse elle a été positive
il ne s'est passé qu'une poignée de jour
avant que l'information soit rendue
publique et j'étais en voyage en
déplacement pour Thalès dans des pays
asiatiques et donc les
premiers contacts que j'ai eu avec les
membres du gouvernement
quant à ce qui était attendu du
président de DF on fait l'objet d'une
réunion collective à laquelle la
ministre participait
et quelles orientations générales vous
êtes-elles partagées la ministre
la réunion collective à laquelle j'ai
participé m'a permis de mesurer
l'ampleur des sujets que je ne
connaissais qu'en tant que lecteur de la
presse ou attentif à ce qui se passe
dans les sur les grandes orientations de
de mon pays
la l'ampleur des du sujet m'a conduit à
demander à ce qu'une lettre de mission
me soit adressée alors le temps que tout
ça soit mise en route
elle m'a été donc adressée début 2015
elle est cosignée des trois ministres
ayant à ce moment-là la tutelle d'EDF
donc la ministre Madame Royale mais
aussi les deux ministres de Bercy qui
partagent la tutelle d'EDF à ce
moment-là dans l'organisation
gouvernementale
et au-delà de la lettre quel était
l'esprit de cette lettre de mission en
particulier les orientations et égales
du regard à notre parc nucléaire
le l'esprit de la lettre de mission
d'abord j'ai partagé cette lettre de
mission avec le conseil d'administration
d'EDF et avec mon comité exécutif
j'estime que c'était un point de départ
important donc la lettre rappelle la
nécessité d'assurer les grandes
objectifs du service public qui est EDF
en matière de nucléaire elle rappelle
que la loi qui n'est pas votée encore à
l'époque puisqu'elle est définitivement
promulguée en août 2015 c'est-à-dire
8 9 mois après mon arrivée faudrait
faire le décompte exacts cette que c'est
toi qui est en train d'être voté prévoit
la baisse à 50% de la de la part du
nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité en 2050 et légalement la
fermeture de Fessenheim cette
lettre de mission qu'il faudrait que je
relise mais je pense qu'elle elle me
demande aussi de préparer la prochaine
génération de PR au-delà de Flamanville
elle inclut la nécessité pour EDF de
préparer le renouvellement du parc
nucléaire
merci vous vous dites avec le modestie
qui vous au nord que vous n'êtes pas un
spécialiste du secteur quand vous
arrivez mais j'imagine que vous échangez
avec vos équipes et avec les techniciens
quelle est l'heure et du coup quel est
votre intime conviction sur cette
nouvelle direction donnée à notre
politique nucléaire en l'occurrence
d'abord l'objectif de 50 % et puis
quelques mois et années après qui se
décline sous la forme de fermeture de
réacteurs
si j'ai si j'ai accepté de prendre la
direction d'une entreprise publique
comme EDF que j'avais connu de loin
lorsque je travaillais moi-même au sein
d'un ministère de l'Industrie qui
d'ailleurs à l'époque incluait les
grandes entreprises énergétiques qui
étaient même des établissements publics
à l'époque c'est bien que que je sais
que le président d'EDF se doit
d'appliquer les les lois et les
règlements je l'ai rappelé dans mon
propos introductif donc je n'ai pas
d'opinion personnelle à avoir ou alors
je ne prends pas le poste si j'estime
que la la politique qui est menée ne me
correspond pas du tout mais j'estime que
s'il m'est proposé une telle
responsabilité pour mon pays il est de
mon devoir d'accepter quoi que je pense
de tel ou telle mesure que le
gouvernement est amené à préparer
je rappelle qu'à l'époque la loi n'est
pas votée
donc vous n'étiez pas en contradiction
avec c'est en aucun contradictions
suffisamment importante avec ses
objectifs pour refuser le poste et les
responsabilités que ça implique
c'est exact
je remercie quand vous arrivez à la tête
de DF quel est l'état de la filière
nucléaire et quel est l'état des
compétences au sein de DF je vous pose
cette question parce qu'on a eu
l'honneur d'interroger vos prédécesseurs
qui nous ont décrit finalement une
situation initiale pas mauvaise en
arrivant à leur responsabilité et pas
mauvaise non plus y compris en termes de
compétences sauf pour quelques hauts
responsables à leur à leur sortie et
donc j'ai bien peur qu'on arrive à notre
époque sans avoir pu identifier de
difficultés en matière de compétences
dans la filière nucléaire et dans EDF
alors que pourtant tout un chacun
convient aujourd'hui d'un problème de
compétences est-ce que vous pouvez nous
aider à y voir plus clair
je crois que il y a deux natures de
compétences très différentes d'ailleurs
j'ai eu l'occasion d'y répondre lors
d'une la question numéro 11 que vous
m'aviez posé monsieur le rapporteur et
je suppose que tout ça sera rendu public
ou est déjà public les questions écrites
que j'ai rédigé sera
sera en tout cas moi je souhaite que ça
soit rendu public et je ne l'ai pas fait
d'accord en tout cas les réponses que
j'ai préparées
moi je n'ai aucune raison de de les
cacher je pense que
voilà et donc je voudrais bien dire
qu'il y a deux sujets très différents
les compétences pour garder le parc en
état de façon à ce qu'il puisse
fonctionner correctement et répondre aux
prescriptions de la autorité de sûreté
nucléaire qui sont d'ailleurs renforcés
après l'accident de Fukushima et qui
sont également mis à jour avec la
perspective de dépasser des 40 ans de
durée de vie
donc des compétences qui sont liées au
parc et puis des compétences qui sont
liées à la construction de nouvelles
centrales je n'ai aucun doute que des f
à les compétences avaient a et j'espère
bien aura les compétences pour gérer son
parc et pour assurer
en les réussissant les
prescriptions pour répondre aux
prescriptions que lui demande l'Autorité
de Sûreté Nucléaire et c'est bien le cas
je crois qu'il n'y a pas d'autre que
nous avons les compétences pour gérer le
parc pas de doute là-dessus et
d'ailleurs nous avons répondu alors à
tel ou tel endroit on était un peu en
avance puis à tel ou tel endroit on
était un peu en retard nous avons
répondu à l'ensemble de ce que
l'Autorité de sûreté nous a demandé de
faire à la suite de l'accident de
Fukushima et nous avons répondu à
l'ensemble de ce que l'Autorité de
sûreté nous a demandé de faire pour
aller au-delà de 40 ans sur les
réacteurs 900 MW puisque il doit y avoir
6 7 8 de ces réacteurs qui aujourd'hui
ont été autorisés à redémarrer au-delà
de ces 40 ans
pas de doute là-dessus ce qui concerne
le niveau de ses compétences en revanche
en ce qui concerne le volume des
compétences on le voit au moment de la
corrosion sous contrainte lorsqu'il y a
un problème générique qui traite d'un
grand nombre de qui touche un grand
nombre de réacteurs nous sommes limités
par le volume de personnes qualifiées
que nous avons
sur la corrosion sous contrainte on me
dit que nous avons environ 100 ou
d'heures qualifié qui vont et vous le
savez dans des conditions de dosimétrie
de radioactivité qui sont difficiles qui
vont réparer le les réacteurs et
d'ailleurs en tout cas au moment où je
suis parti il y a trois semaines
certains des réacteurs les réparations
étaient terminées
et ces réacteurs redémarraient ou à
l'air redémarrer pour suite aux arrêts
de tranches qui les qui les concerné
mais sur la maintenance du parc avec son
soudeur on ne fait pas autant que de
sang et les équipes que j'ai interrogé
m'ont dit que on aurait pu aller plus
vite pour réparer
le parc si on avait eu plutôt de son
soudeur que 100 comme on les avait pas
et ben pour parer au plus pressé on a
fait venir des soudeurs de l'étranger
qui n'avait pas nécessairement
exactement les mêmes gestes les mêmes
qualifications enfin au moins ils
étaient là et on attend pas un an parce
que les soudeurs français ne peuvent pas
revenir sur un chantier moins d'un an
après avoir travaillé compte tenu de la
dosimétrie donc on a parlé au plus
pressé mais il est évident que si on
avait été en train de construire des
nouvelles centrales nucléaires on aurait
eu des dizaines de soudeurs sur des
chantiers de construction neuve et qu'on
leur aurait dit bah écoutez vous pendant
deux mois trois mois je ne sais pas
venez réparer au plus tôt le parc et
puis votre chantier Apani à Gravelines
je ne sais et bien il attendra de moi ou
trois mois le temps que vous soyez
détourné de votre chantier de
construction pour aller sur un chantier
de maintenance donc nous avons les comp
mais nous n'avons pas assez de
compétences il me semble avoir parlé
d'un manque de bras dans une
un moment où je m'exprimais là-dessus
en ce qui concerne la compétence en
matière de
construction je porte un jugement très
différent de celui que je porte sur les
compétences en matière de maintenant car
nous avons construit le parc
jusqu'au 2002 les derniers réacteurs ont
été mis en service en 2002 puis a été
décidé l'unique exemplaire en France de
Flamanville dont la construction a
démarré vers 2007-2008 au niveau du
génie civil mais qui correspond à peu
près une quinzaine d'années après que le
génie civil était fait à à chaud et à
Civaux et donc les différents corps de
métiers qui construisent bien il s'étage
sur une dizaine d'années on aimerait que
ça soit un peu plus rapide 8 à 10 ans et
donc il s'est passé une quinzaine
d'années entre le moment où tel ou tel
corps de métier était sur les chantiers
de chaux et de Civaux et le moment où
tel ou tel corps de métier était
uniquement sur Flamanville
et puis à nouveau après Flamanville pas
de nouvelles constructions immédiate pas
de nouvelles constructions au bout de
cinq ans pas de nouvelles constructions
au bout de 10 ans et maintenant ça fait
15 ans et donc quels sont aujourd'hui
nos compétences en matière de
construction sachant que flamme en ville
il est terminé il y a des réparations à
faire mais le chantier il est terminé si
on va sur place tout a été nettoyé tous
les systèmes sont prêts il y a juste à
terminer quelques réparations
principalement des des défauts des
soudures défectueuses qu'elle est
aujourd'hui l'état de notre capacité à
nous en France de construction sachant
qu'il se passe à peu près 15 ans entre
la fin de la construction du parc actuel
et le démarrage d'un seul réacteur à
flamant ville et puis qui va se passer à
nouveau une quinzaine d'années avant je
l'espère que sois prise des décisions
définitives de construction de même
plutôt et peut-être pas loin de 20 ans
des constructions définitives de
construction de
des décisions définitives de
construction de nouveaux réacteurs et
bien ceci est une préoccupation qui est
très expliqué dans le rapport de
Jean-Martin folle ce qui est public une
trentaine de pages rapporte qui date de
fin 2019 qui a été qui a été rendu
public
à cette époque là et qui explique la
nécessité bien de remettre en marche une
filière au niveau des métiers de la
construction qui est notoirement
insuffisante au moment où le rapport est
produit en 2019 dans la foulée du
rapport pardon pour ma réponse qui est
un peu longue monsieur le rapporteur
mais c'est un point ce sont des points
évidemment fondamentaux dans la foulée
du rapport folle
je crée une nouvelle direction qui met
directement rattachée au sein d'EDF qui
lance je fais venir un expert industriel
qui vient du monde de l'automobile
ou technologie mais aussi beaucoup de
grands programmes avec la volonté de
sortir la voiture au bon moment et pas
un an après les concurrents évidemment
une très grande discipline dans la
gestion des grands projets et ce
directeur qui me rapporte qui s'appelle
Alain Transer lance un plan qui
s'appelle le plan Excel qui vise à
améliorer le niveau de compétence et la
qualité d'exécution des nouveaux
chantiers peut-être aussi des chantiers
sur le parc actuel mais principalement
des nouveaux chantiers et donc le plan
Rexel est un grand programme de remontée
des niveaux de compétences et des
volumes de compétences et du niveau de
qualité qui est mise en place au sein
d'EDF mais en associant très largement
les entreprises du secteur regrouper au
sein du du gifen et pour être tout à
fait transparent ce plan Excel fait
l'objet d'une présentation annuelle au
conseil d'administration d'EDF et dans
la foulée d'une conférence de presse de
façon à ce que l'ensemble du public sont
informés des objectifs et des
avancements du plan Excel
je vous remercie je comprends donc que
le diagnostic que vous faites vous ne le
faites pas seulement j'imagine depuis
quelques semaines mais depuis de longues
années au sein de DF que c'est pour ça
que vous avez mis en place ces
programmes ces programmes-là et donc à
nouveau sans chercher de responsabilité
polémique que c'est bien une situation
dont vous avez
hérité à votre arrivée au sein de DF
pour les différentes raisons
structurantes que vous avez pu expliquer
je vous laisse me couper si vous n'êtes
pas d'accord mais si vous êtes d'accord
je continue
pardon je crois qu'il est clair que
on peut pas dire qu'on est compétent et
efficace quand on construit un réacteur
tous les 15 ans c'est pas possible donc
on s'est interrompu ensuite on a lancé
Flamanville pour des raisons dont je ne
suis pas sûr de bien comprendre après
après Flamanville on n'a pas continué
avec d'autres réacteurs alors que
c'était vraiment à l'ordre du jour mais
ça s'est interrompu la crise financière
je sais pas très bien ce qui s'est passé
j'étais pas du tout aux responsabilités
à ce moment-là et bien aujourd'hui il
s'agit de redémarrer un programme
d'ampleur puisque dans le discours de
Belfort le président de la République a
parlé de 6 et même peut-être de 14
réacteurs et donc il faut qu'on soit
prêt c'est ce que le président de
l'Autorité sur tes nucléaire a appelé le
besoin d'un plan Marshall et moi je fais
volontiers
bien c'est ses propres paroles et donc
on s'y prépare et on sait que il y a
devant nous un énorme le chantier un
énorme travail à faire pour acquérir la
crédibilité et répondre aux besoins de
ce programme
je vous remercie d'ailleurs sur le plan
des compétences au-delà même des
compétences techniques vous décrivez
votre surprise en ce qui concerne le
chantier de père à votre arrivée vous
décrivez des principes de gestion de
projet commun aux autres projets
industriels qui n'ont visiblement pas
cours chez EDF ou décrivez la dilution
des responsabilités la faiblesse des
interactions entre des f et Areva
l'absence de direction église dédiée à
l'ingénierie du projet bref votre
description sur la capacité à gérer un
tel projet par EDF dépasse largement la
question des compétences techniques si
je comprends bien je sauf si vous voulez
réagir sur ce point pour tes raisons et
là aussi j'ai rédigé le texte que vous
lisez la réponse à l'une de vos
questions et je pense en effet qu'en
matière de gestion de projet que de
direction de programme Flamenville
n'était pas piloté comme il aurait dû
l'être j'ai essayé de
résoudre ce sujet dans les semaines les
mois qui ont suivi mon arrivée en
réorganisant ça selon les principes de
gestion de grands projets industriels
que avait appris dans d'autres secteurs
mais vous conviendrez surtout égard à
l'expérience que vous aviez déjà dans
d'autres secteurs industriels que pour
un projet de cette ampleur et de cette
importance pour EDF il était étonnant
que le plus haut niveau de direction au
sein de DF ne se soit pas saisi du sujet
pleinement comme vous l'avez fait
semble-t-il à votre arrivée
je vous convient bien oui
je vous remercie une question sur
la filière nucléaire cette fois sur le
l'état d'Areva
et les différentes décisions qui ont été
prises jusqu'au sessions des activités
de fabrication de réacteurs nucléaires
sans vous demander de faire l'historique
cherche à comprendre deux choses la
première chose c'est l'implication ou
non des pouvoirs publics indirects sous
forme d'arbitrage de recommandations et
bien sûr en tant que actionnaire comment
est-ce que vous jugez la stratégie de
l'État actionnaire dans cette dans cette
évolution et qui a conduit jusqu'à la
session a EDF d'une partie enfin d'une
partie de la base de la filiale de la
filiale correspondante à la fabrication
des réacteurs nucléaires est-ce que vous
jugez comme d'autres que c'est davantage
les décisions individuelles prises au
sein d'Areva qui ont conduit aux échecs
qu'on connaît
je suis pas capable de répondre à cette
question puisque cette décision ont été
prises plusieurs années avant mon
arrivée ce que je peux vous dire
peut-être pour éclairer un petit peu
l'histoire sans sans tomber dans
l'anecdote c'est que dans cette première
réunion collective au retour d'Asie où
je prends connaissance de ce que l'État
me demande de faire sur EDF évidemment
le sujet de la mauvaise santé d'arriva
est abordé et le fait qu'il va falloir
trouver une solution pour remettre les
choses d'équerre donc là on est en
octobre 2014
octobre novembre 2014 cette solution
elle est préparée de concerts par la
nouvelle présidente d'Areva et la
nouvelle présidente d'EDF sous
l'autorité du gouvernement et elle fait
si je ne m'abuse l'objet d'un communiqué
de presse de l'Élysée le 3 juin 2015 qui
explique comment tout cela a évolué va
évoluer et ensuite il s'agit de de bien
exécuter cette
cette décision stratégique qui produit
en fait on va pas rentrer trop dans les
détails mais à donner à EDF le rôle
d'unique chef de fil de la construction
de réacteurs nucléaires de faire de
framatoes qui correspond à l'ancien
arrêt à NP et qui retrouve le nom du
Framatome des années 60 70 80 et 90 de
faire de Framatome le responsable de la
chaudière et le responsable d'un grand
nombre des équipements qui sont
installés dans cette chaudière et puis
de faire doranos qui a été COGEMA
également pendant une trentaine d'années
et je crois que cette décision de
principe est bonne en tout cas à
l'époque je l'ai fortement soutenu je
vais plutôt plaisir enfin j'avais plutôt
plaisir jusqu'au 23 novembre à voir les
résultats opérationnels de Framatome
revenus dans une situation profitable
une situation de croissance une
situation d'attractivité pour des
ingénieurs et des salariés en général de
recons d'ailleurs un bloc industriel en
élargissant un petit peu les compétences
de Framatome sans s'interdire de
procéder à des acquisitions et de voir
d'un autre côté Orano conduire conduire
avec efficacité les contrats que EDF lui
avait confié donc je pense que cette
restructuration de la filière qui
est
devient très urgente fin 2014 qui est
décidé dans son principe en juin 2015 et
exécuté jusqu'à fin 2017 ça a eu
beaucoup de retard sur le sujet à cause
de la dimension finlandaise du dossier
je crois que c'est une bonne décision de
politique industrielle dont on bénéficie
aujourd'hui
mais alors il y a quelque chose qui
m'échappe on construit on est en train
de construire sur la responsabilité
d'EDF un nouvel EPR on
redonne un peu de vitalité à la filière
avec ses séries organisations ça suffit
pas à ça suffit pas à redonner une forme
d'appétit ou d'attractivité pour la
filière industrielle nucléaire en termes
de compétences c'est le seul fait qu'on
ait lancé un seul EPR en 2005 qui fait
que
EDF depuis des années avant votre mandat
est sous votre mandat ne trouve pas ces
fameux bras
EDF embauche les bras dont il a l'emploi
il ne s'agit pas de savoir si on arrive
à faire ou non venir des ingénieurs des
soudeurs dans la filière il s'agit de
savoir quel travail leur donne ton à
faire
pour l'essentiel le chantier de
Flamanville est terminé vers 2017-2018
depuis nous ne faisons que réparer
et donc la quasi-totalité des besoins de
DF des bras dont nous avons besoin ce
sont des besoins pour la maintenance du
parc et cela nous l'assurant
à ce qui est prévisible pas
l'imprévisible de la corrosion sous
contrainte mais à ce qui est prévisible
et les chantiers du du parc se déroule
toute façon de toute manière de façon
comment dire
de façon très très
programmé alors il y a des perturbations
majeures qui vont naître de la covid ça
c'est quelque chose de d'imprévu qui qui
dont on paye encore les conséquences
aujourd'hui mais nous aurions eu plus de
bras si nous avions eu des réacteurs à
construire mais nous avons eu un
réacteur à construire de ces 20
dernières années et il est terminé
depuis 5 ans
il s'agit de réparer oui d'accord on a
besoin de gérer pareil mais enfin les
gens qui font les câblages les gens qui
font les les systèmes de contrôle
commande ou autre ils ont fini leur
travail et tout est terminé
donc le volume de main d'oeuvre dont
vous disposiez était suffisant pour
maintenir le parc sauf en ce moment
parce que il y a selon vous une
conjonction d'événements qui explique le
retard mais pas pour construire de
nouveaux réacteurs
c'est tout à fait cela merci beaucoup
néanmoins à de multiples reprises et
j'ai sous les yeux à un avis de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire de mai
la question d'un défaut générique grave
a été mentionné comme une problématique
pour la sécurité d'approvisionnement je
sais tout simplement la conclusion d'une
partie de la vie la SN rappelle
l'importance de disposer de marge
suffisantes dans le système électrique
pour faire face à la nécessité de
suspendre simultanément le
fonctionnement de plusieurs réacteurs
qui présenterait un défaut générique
grave
t'imagines que EDF ne serait-ce que dans
ces discussions de filière avec RTE pour
préparer les scénarios de consommation
de production à évoquer cette question
qu'est-ce qui je comprends bien que la
question technique du de la corrosion
sous contrainte de ce phénomène récent
inconnu et donc est difficile à
identifier pour toutes les raisons qui
ont déjà été expliquées ne soient pas
tels mais quels étaient les réflexions
autour des défauts génériques graves
le propre du du défaut générique grave
c'est que vous ne savez ni quand il va
arriver ni de quoi il va s'agir ni
qu'elle va en être l'ampleur et donc la
question que vous posez c'est une
question d'assurance et de réassurance
c'est une question de marge de manœuvre
et
les travaux que des f mènent avec RTE
pour établir des scénarios et des
réponses à des scénarios de dégradation
montre que nous estimons avoir
suffisamment de marge de manœuvre pour
faire face mais bien on dit scénario des
scénarios de stress est-ce qu'on a les
marges de manœuvre pour faire face au
scénario de stress et d'ailleurs les
mois qui viennent vont nous dire si nous
avons ou non les marges de manœuvre pour
faire face au scénario de stress parce
que pour l'instant les Français ont de
l'électricité
je vous remercie deux dernières
questions une série les énergies
renouvelables à votre arrivée à la tête
de DF vous montez la stratégie cap 2030
qui prévoit de passer de 28 gigawatts de
puissance installée à 50 gigawatts en
2030 sauf erreur est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire ce qui préside à ce choix à ce
50 gigawatts en a un problème avec les
50 jours et comment évolue l'objectif au
fur et à mesure de votre mandat
le sujet des énergies renouvelables est
un est un sujet
qui est délicat en France
il est il est délicat parce que certains
voudraient voudraient faire croire que
on peut vivre dans un système avec 100%
d'énergie renouvelable et la
surinvestissement qui correspondrait à
un tel système et passer sous silence
rien n'est impossible mais s'il s'agit
de surinvestir pour pouvoir démontrer
quelque chose et d'oublier l'aspect
économique je crois que
il faut le dire
chacun voit que l'hiver
il fait froid donc on a besoin
d'électricité mais malheureusement
souvent il y a très très peu de vent
donc s'il faut sur investir pour assurer
le service de l'électricité l'hiver
quand il y a très très peu de vent alors
qu'on va multiplier
les
installations et pas de soleil bien sûr
on va multiplier les installations pour
faire face à ce cas on voit bien qu'on
arrive à une impasse
et donc la question du
quantum d'énergie renouvelable et
fait l'objet de débat un peu
nous nous avons essayé de vivre avec la
loi 50%
plus l'hydro 10 % madame bastiste bien
donc ça fait à peu près 60 à peu près
60% d'énergie pilotable et que à quoi à
quoi ressemble un système électrique
français avec 50% de nucléaires c'est la
loi 10% on constate c'est
l'hydroélectricité on aimerait bien
faire mieux mais on peut pas peut-être y
revenir plus tard et puis aller 35%
peut-être de
d'énergie renouvelable et on a vu que ça
conduisait à des besoins d'énergie
renouvelables qui sont tout à fait
considérables et les travaux de
planification qu'on a fait en interne au
premier semestre 2015 peu de temps après
mon arrivée de façon à ce que EDF
dispose d'une vision stratégique à
l'horizon 2030 15 ans plus tard qui soit
complète qui soit exhaustive parce que
l'une de mes surprises aussi en arrivant
chez EDF c'est que il y a des
optimisations mais elles sont un peu
locales il y a pas une vision globale de
ce qui est EDF en 2030 c'est pour ça que
je lance cap 2030 et donc ça nous
conduit à nous dire nous on aimerait
bien dans ce dans le cadre de cette
planification énergétique qui relève du
gouvernement qui relève de la loi en
train d'être voté on très bien arriver à
50 gigawatts ça nous semble un bon
exercice sachant que en 2030 on voit
bien que l'hydroélectrique va rester à
peu près comme il est où il augmentera
pas beaucoup et que donc le solde
viendra d'éolien et de soleil
le
problème de des énergies des énergies
renouvelables
c'est comme on gère le système
électrique mais c'est aussi comment on
les finances
alors le système électrique c'est RTE
mais EDF joue évidemment un rôle un rôle
important
on s'inquiète quand même d'une nouvelle
dépendance
aujourd'hui
éolien et le solaire ça représente 7 ou
8% de la production
si demain ça doit représenter 30 ou 40%
de la de la production on va créer une
nouvelle dépendance comme celle qu'on
voit le danger avec le gaz russe
vis-à-vis d'importation qui viennent de
Chine de cellules solaires et de moteur
de turbine de turbine d'éolienne donc je
pense qu'il faut se poser la question et
en plus on sent la Commission européenne
l'Union européenne le Parlement européen
totalement
ne portant aucun intérêt à ce sujet de
la création de nouvelles dépendances
d'ailleurs une de mes surprises aussi
tellement pendant mes 8 ans c'est qu'un
jour il a été décidé au niveau de
l'Europe que les les taxes qui étaient
mises sur les cellules solaires en
provenance de Chine pour essayer quand
même de donner un petit avantage
compétitif à ceux qui essayent de
produire en Europe cet axe d'un jour ou
l'autre on disparu
donc il faut que la doctrine européenne
évolue il me semble là-dessus mais
peut-être ça va être le cas avec le
mécanisme aux frontières qui est en
train d'être finalisé alors ensuite le
financement du passage de 28 à 50
gigawatts repose sur un certain nombre
d'hypothèses j'ai beaucoup parlé de la
reine
je n'ai pas eu les moyens économiques
les moyens financiers de
de passer sur un rythme le rythme que
j'aurais voulu et néanmoins on a
rattrapé une grande partie de notre
retard en matière d'énergie d'énergie
renouvelable on la rattrapé avec
un gros effort le plan solaire notamment
un effort aussi de
conviction des
populations concernées qui est un sujet
difficile dont certains de vos collègues
s'occupent peut-être en ce moment même
comment accélérer les renouvelables en
France mais fondamentalement si on n'est
pas tout à fait sur le rythme de 50 GW
c'est parce qu'on n'a pas eu les moyens
financiers de le faire et néanmoins on a
presque rattrapé notre principal
concurrent en matière de volume
d'électricité renouvelable produite en
France hors hydraulique éolien plus
solaire on a rattrapé notre concurrent
pas tout à fait presque
une dernière question pour ma part
est-ce que qu'il s'agisse des énergies
renouvelables de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement de l'état du parc
nucléaire depuis 2015 vous avez émis en
privé j'imagine vu votre position des
alertes importantes au pouvoir public et
si oui est-ce que vous avez l'impression
d'avoir été entendu ou pas
vous savez la réponse c'est pas
positive ni complètement négatif je
pense avoir
eu l'occasion de m'exprimer auprès des
autorités politiques de façon régulière
et je pense avoir été largement entendu
je pense avoir été également
un bon comment dire témoin de la manière
dont l'entreprise avec tout ce qu'elle
entraîne derrière elle les salariés
l'ensemble des entreprises qui
travaillent pour le compte d'EDF et qui
sont nombreuses je pense que tout ceci a
été respecté j'ai été reconduit
également en 2019 ce qui
n'était pas arrivé depuis très très
longtemps
et
donc je dirais que que d'une manière
générale le dialogue que j'ai pu avoir
avec les autorités politiques étaient un
dialogue qui était assez naturel et
assez riche
donc à part le point que vous avez
régulièrement mentionné évoqué de
l'arène vous considérez que l'ensemble
des alertes que vous avez menées sur la
viabilité de DF les projets importants à
mener pour EDF pour notre sécurité
d'approvisionnement ont été entendu
EDF a eu les moyens
que l'État lui a donné de résoudre cette
équation financière tellement délicate
créée par la reine l'État a essayé de
faire évoluer la reine dans le cadre du
projet d'Hercule qui a fait lui aussi
couler beaucoup d'encre qui a été porté
par le gouvernement auprès de la
Commission en essayant de résoudre le
problème de la reine à l'intérieur d'une
réforme plus importante dans les années
2019-2020 2021 la Commission européenne
la direction de la concurrence de la
Commission européenne a mis des
obstacles telles à l'évolution que
souhaitait simultanément concomitamment
le gouvernement français et l'entreprise
nous avions travaillé beaucoup ensemble
évidemment c'était au gouvernement de
portée à la Commission le dossier donc
ceci permettait de résoudre le problème
le problème de la reine mais quand il a
fallu venir aider EDF à mettre en oeuvre
ses principales missions l'État était
présent je rappelle que l'État n'a pas
pris sauf à une petite exception près
n'a pas pris de dividendes en cash à EDF
depuis 2015 et qui a trois reprises
l'État a participé à des opérations de
marché en investisseurs avisés de façon
à améliorer la structure du bilan de
déesse c'était le 42 2017 augmentation
de capital de 4 milliards d'euros
c'était le cas à nouveau en 22 avec une
nouvelle augmentation de capital et dans
l'intervalles nous avions eu une
émission d'obligation convertible à
laquelle l'État avait également souscrit
de façon importante et donc
nos équilibres
financiers étaient extrêmement tendu
mais EDF a pu assurer l'essentiel de ses
missions même si une nouvelle fois je
regrette que nous n'ayons pas eu plus de
moyens pour nous développer dans des
énergies renouvelables et être sur la
bonne trajectoire des 50 GW que j'avais
visé dès 2015
merci Monsieur Tanguy
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur Lévy pour votre présence et
pour les réponses que vous avez
apportées pour le moment j'ai plusieurs
questions sur les enjeux extrêmement
importants que vous avez découvert
pendant de longues années tout d'abord
vous avez parlé très brièvement des
barrages de la filière hydroélectrique
pour vous quelles conséquences a eu le
fait de ne pas eu d'arbitrage dans un
sens ou dans l'autre sur la question de
l'attribution définitive des concessions
de barrage est-ce que ça a détérioré la
capacité à investir peut-être à faire
des changements technologies notamment
dans la capacité peut-être d'améliorer
un peu les turbines et la productivité
des centrales d'investir dans des
nouvelles steps vous avez parlé
vous-même d'ailleurs de l'accord de
Paris et donc est-ce que finalement la
solution hydraulique a même avec une
participation mesurée évidemment et ça
fait pas de promettre n'importe quoi
est-ce que c'est 10 ans de perdu quand
même n'ont pas entachés notre capacité à
justement respecter la corde Paris avec
une énergie à la fois rentabilisée
souveraine stockable et le même et le
même à la fois stockable et source de
stock et qui est capable d'être un stock
en elle-même et
voilà donc est-ce que ça n'a pas dégradé
la réalisation des objectifs est pris
est fait prendre un retard considérable
ensuite vous avez parlé du prix de
production est-ce que vous-même vous
pouvez estimer aujourd'hui il va le prix
de production réelle du parc que dirige
EDF et aussi pris de production du parc
EDF et prix de production du parc
François général une fois que vous avez
intégré les tarifs de rachat normaux du
de l'éolien et du photovoltaïque est-ce
que aussi EDF avait une estimation du
prix de production réelle si on sortait
du marché européen de la fin de la
formation pardon de la formation des
prix du Market design des prix européens
est-ce que EDF avait une estimation qui
traînait pour savoir combien ça
coûterait réellement à la France si on
revenait au prix moyen de production et
non au coût marginal il y a une
estimation qui traîne de plusieurs
experts qui parlent Bonnant ma langue
depuis le début du crise du gaz la prix
moyen de production
en intégrant les importations entre 80
et 120 euros le mégawattheure est-ce que
ça vous paraît une échelle de prix
acceptable cohérente en tout cas aussi
le coût pour EDF de la reine j'ai
interrogé monsieur Proglio hier qui n'a
pas pu répondre quel coût a représenté
la reine sous votre mandat pour les
finances de DF est-ce qu'il y a une
estimation qui existe est-ce que c'est
un chiffre qui est connu ou calculé ou
est-ce que comme nous l'a dit Monsieur
Proglio c'est à la représentation
nationale de s'inquiéter de ce que la
reine a coûté pour EDF et donc pour le
contribuable consommateur le président
de la commission vous a interrogé sur
l'accord de la fermeture de Fessenheim
j'aimerais plus précisément vous
interviewer sur les conditions de
l'accord financier qui étaient trouvées
avec le gouvernement hier monsieur
Proglio a clairement sous-entendu que
cet accord ne représentait pas la valeur
économique réelle de scorer représenter
l'exploitation de Fessenheim sur 10 à
fortiori 20 ans supplémentaire de la
même façon quand vous avez quitté EDF ou
en été précisément le démantèle de
Fessenheim est-ce que oui ou non il y a
des étapes vraiment irréversibles qui
ont été menées ou est-ce que si on le
souhaitait alors dans un temps dans un
temps évidemment raisonnable ou pas
d'ailleurs graisse à votre appréciation
et ce qui pourrait y avoir un moyen de
relancer Fessenheim sur une une façon ou
d'une autre
option est-ce que on peut aussi relancer
Fessenheim à vos yeux si on profitait en
relançant Fessenheim de faire les
travaux nécessaires à un prolongement
jusqu'à 60 ans de se directeurs comme un
démonstrateur
une démonstration de la capacité
technologique de le faire en conditions
réelles puisqu'on a un exemple pour
sauter finalement une une échéance
décennale vous avez parlé de des
rapports RTE vous avez été critiques des
perspectives de consommation alors je me
félicite de l'échelle de 750 à 800
terwatters de consommation que vous avez
donné puisque c'est l'échelle qui a
donné l'oration nationale aux dernières
élections présidentielles bien seul bien
isolé sous les critiques et les RIC
généraux puisque nous nous avions une
échelle de 770 à 820 Tera Watters pour
2050 nous sommes les seuls à avoir fait
cette échelle au-delà de la consommation
quelles sont vos tarifs de la production
notamment ce que RTE appelle les paris
technologiques est-ce que vous savez ce
que veut dire RTE puisque personne n'est
capable de nous dire ce que cela
signifie aussi est-ce que vous
considérez normal que RTE est enterré le
scénario de maintenir la production
nucléaire à 70 à 60 70 voir supérieur
pourquoi pas 80% pourquoi ces scénarios
ont été enterrés ce que vous estimez
entreprises en EDF que le fait que RTE
aille au bout de ses scénarios soit
utile à ce titre le gouvernement est RTE
nous a expliqué que c'était parce que la
filière nucléaire nous avait dit que
c'était impossible de de maintenir une
telle production d'ici 2050 ce n'est pas
ce qu'elle ce qu'a dit l'ensemble des
acteurs de la filière que j'ai rencontré
depuis de nombreuses années c'est
d'ailleurs visiblement pas non plus ce
que vous auriez dit selon un article du
Point madame Géraldine Wessner vous cite
sur cette question justement que la
filière aurait dit c'est impossible de
faire plus de réacteurs je vous cite
est-ce que vous confirmez cette citation
je n'ai jamais dit cela confié au point
la mine sombre le patron d'EDF la
Bernard Lévy
citation dans un monde idéal un monde où
les gouvernements successifs garderaient
la même politique et cesserait de faire
un du stop and go on pourrait construire
un réacteur nucléaire par an entre 2035
et 2040 puis monté à deux réacteurs par
an on saurait le faire il faut il faut
planifier le bureau d'études les besoins
à génie civils les lignes d'assemblage
tout est possible avancer Jean-Bernard
Lévy est-ce que vous pouvez confirmer ou
infirmer cette analyse si cela ne vous
dérange pas ensuite sur quelques retours
de chantier sur inclipoint vous avez
parlé du cours de du contrat qui a été
fait et de la Cour des comptes
britanniques il me semble que la cour
des cambritanniques donne un élément
très intéressant qui était très rarement
commenté qui est des conséquences du
coût du capital ou de enfin c'est pas la
formule c'est en anglais donc je sais
plus là mais en gros le prix de enfin le
prix de de l'argent qui qui est prêté à
l'opérateur pour construire EDF et que
si ce prêt si ce coût est proche de zéro
ou à deux même à 2%, le prix de
l'électricité nucléaire de l'epers
s'effondre et s'effondre de mémoire
entre 20 et 40 euros au livre La Paris
je ne sais plus le méga amateur enfin en
tout cas bien loin du prix qui est
indiqué donc pour les conditions de
financement pour que ça peut intéresser
la représentation nationale pour le
refinancement d'un nouveau plan
nucléaire serait très intéressant
effectivement peut-être d'élaborer un
plan de financement qui va vers des taux
d'intérêt plutôt proche de 2 que du taux
de marché puisque ça n'a pas
considérable en fait sur le prix de
l'électricité nucléaire et c'est très
peu évoqué je trouve ça dommage il
voulait avoir votre analyse là dessus
sur les retours aussi de Ty Chan on a
très peu d'informations sur ce qui s'est
passé à tihan est-ce que vous en avez
vraiment est-ce que ce que les
informations qu'on nous ont été données
de la Chine vous semble crédible puisque
pareil s'il y a des problèmes de
conception
tels qui ont été qui semble remonter ce
que ça pourrait avoir des conséquences
pour Flamanville ou pour même nos
partenaires finlandais britanniques
qui ressort vous avez parlé du le père
britannique est-ce que oui ou non il a
bien été simplifié dans son design et ce
que le père britannique n'a plus grand
chose à voir avec le père finlandais par
exemple et en lien avec ce que vous
aviez sur le risque de dents de
nouvelles de nouveaux chroniques clairs
entre la fin de flamant ville et les
vrais acteurs que pourrait lancer le
gouvernement actuel et ce qui vous
semble oui ou non pertinent d'attendre
un opère 2 avec les risques aussi de
validation du design de la SN puisqu'on
nous présente la validation du premier
design de l'EPRD comme une évidence or
il y a aucune raison que la SN valide le
design de le père de comme parce que
jusqu'à présent la SN a fait preuve de
bien plus de d'exigence donc ça nous est
présenté comme une évidence moi ça me
semble pas avec des risques de reporter
encore plus le chronique clair dans de
nombreuses années pourquoi visiblement à
votre avis le fait de pas prendre le
modèle de père britannique pour lancer
des EPR et après de faire la soudure
avec le père de pourquoi est-ce que ce
scénario semble complètement mis à la
poubelle aussi sous votre mandat il y a
eu visiblement une tentative de chantage
de General Electric sur la maintenance
des turbines arabels est-ce que vous
pouvez nous parler de ce qui s'est passé
dans le dans la négociation de ces
contrats des implications sur la
souveraineté française est-ce que ces
tentative de chantage en abouti de point
de vue des exigences de général
électrique est-ce que l'État a défendu
EDF est la souveraineté française dans
le cadre de ce qui a été annoncé par la
presse donc comme un chantage est-ce
qu'il y a eu d'autres tentatives aussi
sur la maintenance d'autres équipements
de de production électrique je pense à
nos barrages puisque le général
électrique a aussi hérité de l'éditer
turbine hydroélectrique dans ce cas
d'ailleurs de General Electric que
pensez-vous la nomination de l'ukramont
comme votre successeur et notamment de
l'acquisition de la finalisation de la
turbine Arabel sachant que l'ultramont a
donc participé à la vente de turbine
Arabel la génératric et donc maintenant
il va participer à la finalisation du
rachat de la même activité qu'il a vendu
est-ce que vous en tant que responsable
économique de plusieurs grandes
entreprises françaises ça vous paraît
une pratique normale de que le vivement
il soit juste les parties de la même
opération financière
enfin et ce sera ma dernière question
vous avez parlé en tout début
d'intervention des opportunités
d'exploiter les hydrocarbures en France
dans laquelle pour comment dire pour
affermir la souveraineté pardon la
souveraineté énergétique française en
général c'est bien entendu est-ce que
vous pourriez développer ce point ou pas
merci
monsieur
le député je crains de ne pas pouvoir
répondre à tous vos sujets j'ai pas eu
le temps de tout noter donc je vous prie
de m'excuser à l'avance si je ne réponds
que à ceux que j'ai eu le temps de noter
vous avez commencé par
l'hydro-électricité je voudrais revenir
quelques instants là dessus
la Commission a mis en demeure à deux
reprises la France d'appliquer la
directive concession que la France a
accepté il y a maintenant un peu plus de
20 ans
la France a accepté que la directive
concession s'applique à
l'hydroélectricité
la Commission demande à la France
d'accepter mise en place d'une directive
européenne que la France a accepté
maintenant la France et EDF évidemment
partie prenante mais
quel est le sens de mettre en
concurrence des concessions au moment où
ces concessions expirent il s'est
complètement aléatoire au sein d'une
vallée une concession expire une autre
n'explique
n'expire pas il y a une des
optimisations flagrante et puis en quoi
un autre opérateur opérerait-il mieux un
barrage que l'opérateur actuel qui a le
toute la connaissance et toute la masse
critique pour exploiter ça
convenablement et nous sommes donc dans
une impasse depuis très longtemps et
j'ai quitté mes fonctions il y a trois
semaines le dossier n'est pas très
différent de ce qu'il était lorsque j'ai
pris mes fonctions il y a 8 ans
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé pendant cette
période assez peu de choses à vrai dire
puisque en dehors des
justifications que la France donne à la
non-application de la directive
concession peu de choses peuvent être
faites du côté des investissements
pourtant qui serait pourtant bien utile
en nouveau barrage et donc il y a des
possibilités d'améliorer l'exploitation
du potentiel hydroélectrique français
qui sont mises côté depuis des années et
en particulier de créer de nouvelles
stations d'augmenter la puissance mais
surtout de créer de nouvelles stations
de pompage les fameuses steps dont vous
parliez et il y a des projets qui
existent depuis très longtemps
certains m'ont dit qu'ils étaient déjà à
l'ordre du jour
il y a
près de 40 ans
oui parce que finalement le la
disposition des montagnes et des
rivières qui les traversent ne changent
pas et donc les ingénieurs ils se disent
tiens là on pourrait faire quelque chose
d'intelligent et puis finalement les
conditions économiques ne sont pas
remplies à certains moments c'était le
cas il y a quelques décennies
aujourd'hui les prix sont élevés les
conditions économiques pourraient être
remplies mais le droit ne permet pas ne
permet pas de le faire et donc ce qui
s'est passé depuis quelques années c'est
que nous avons tout simplement maintenu
le parc tel qu'il est le parc fonctionne
bien d'ailleurs on peut s'en réjouir au
moment où on en a bien besoin
aujourd'hui je voudrais saluer les
hydro-électriciens d'EDF parce qu'on
parle beaucoup des centrales nucléaires
mais ceux qui exploite les barrages
aujourd'hui font un travail remarquable
pour que ces barrages soient bien
disponibles quand on en a besoin pendant
l'hiver et puis nous avons fait quelques
améliorations de 6 de là de la puissance
de certains barrages nous avons pu
gagner quelques mégawatts à un endroit
quelques dizaines de mégawatts à un
autre endroit mais le dossier n'a pas
n'a pas beaucoup n'a pas beaucoup changé
votre deuxième votre deuxième angle de
de réflexion et de questions portaient
sur les sujets autour du prix du coup
combien leur Ann a-t-il coûté en tout
chaque année
quels sont les quels sont les prix donc
quels sont les prix de revient alors les
prix de revient dépend évidemment des
technologies les prix du nucléaire les
coûts du nucléaire ont été
évoqués je les ai évoqués tout à l'heure
ils avaient été calculés par la creux en
2019 et tournait autour de 50 euros nous
estimons un peu plus de 50 euros la
croix disait un peu moins de 50 euros en
euros de 2019 parce que depuis nous
avons de l'inflation cette inflation
touche évidemment aussi nos achats nos
salaires les taxes que nous payons et
autres et donc c'est pour vous donner
une idée à peu près des coûts du
nucléaire les coûts de l'hydraulique est
bien évidemment l'hydraulique était est
très amorti donc les coûts marginaux de
l'hydraulique sont faibles les coûts de
la production à partir de gaz pas
totalement négligeable sont extrêmement
volatiles aujourd'hui ils très élevé
c'est nous qui font les prix et les
coûts de production du renouvelable
résulte des appels d'offres que nous
gagnons ou que nous ne gagnions pas
quand la Commission de régulation de
l'énergie organise ces appels d'offres
donc au total vous avez une panoplie de
coûts
aujourd'hui qui est qui est extrêmement
variable et donc je ne me reconnais pas
dans le chiffre de 80 ni dans le chiffre
220 je vous donne un coup du nucléaire
qui est celui que la Commission de
régulation de l'énergie à envoyer à la
Commission européenne qui à ma
connaissance avait plutôt accepté qui
était autour d'une cinquantaine d'euros
en euros de 2019 et puis ensuite ça
dépend de la de la volatilité des choses
et du marché
combien la reine a-t-il coûté à EDF
c'est extrêmement difficile à calculer
parce qu'on peut difficilement
faire des simulations précises et même
même grossière sur le comportement des
acteurs économiques s'il n'y avait pas
eu la reine est-ce que nos concurrents
ou auraient ou non investi plutôt que de
se contenter d'attendre que nous leur
livrions le courant électrique que nous
avons produit et que nous avons à la
base sur la base des infrastructures que
nous avons construit donc c'est très
difficile de dire quel est le coût de la
reine ce qui est certain c'est que quand
notre parc nucléaire aujourd'hui son
coup direct sans même parler d'un coup
de reconstruction et d'une cinquantaine
d'euros je rappelle qu'il était question
de le monter à 52 quand je suis arrivé
et que le gouvernement était d'accord
là-dessus le gouvernement de 2014 et
2015 et que vous vous touchez 42 euros
de la même manière maintenant que vous
les touchez en 2000 en 2012 le manga
gagné est tout à fait considérable il
est plusieurs milliards d'euros de
plusieurs milliards d'euros chaque année
vu du producteur que nous sommes mais
quel serait le marché si nos opérateurs
alternatifs avaient été incités à
construire plutôt qu'à parasiter en
quelque sorte le système le système
existant en ce qui concerne Fessenheim
les conditions de l'accord de Fessenheim
je me laisse à mon à mon prédécesseur le
soin de critiquer si s'il a bien fait un
accord qu'il n'a pas négocié moi je me
contenterai de vous dire que cet accord
a fait l'objet de
nombreuses réunions d'un comité
d'administrateurs indépendants au sein
du Conseil d'EDF auquel l'État ne
participait pas et lors du vote de la
résolution approuvant l'accord qui avait
été négocié par mes soins avec avec
l'État
les représentants de l'État se sont
non pas participé au vote en application
des règles de bonne des bonnes
gouvernance donc cet accord a été validé
par la Commission de Bruxelles il ne ce
n'est donc pas une aide d'État si l'état
nous avait aidé il aurait été rejeté il
a été validé par les administrateurs
indépendants qui
représente l'intérêt social de
l'entreprise et cet accord République il
est évidemment très épais et je voudrais
simplement vous dire que il inclut une
somme fixe qui a été versée par l'État
alors je vais me tromper je pense qu'il
a été versé par l'État fin 2019 mais je
voudrais pas dire compte-rendu que c'est
une certitude absolue
mais cette somme fixe a été versée par
l'État et il comprend une somme variable
qui sera versée par l'État 10 ans après
la fermeture en observant ce qui s'est
passé sur le parc à 900 mégawatts
pendant les dix années précédentes et à
nouveau 20 ans après la fermeture en
observant ce qui s'est passé sur le parc
entre la 11e et la 20e année donc il y a
une somme fixe déjà versée et il y aura
où il n'y aura pas selon des formules un
peu compliquées une nouvelle somme qui
sera versée en 2031 et une nouvelle
somme qui sera versée en 2041 donc moi
je ne qualifierais pas la corde savoir
si il est bon sans être en 2041 pour
voir si finalement le manque à gagner
était très significatif où il était
simplement lié à fixe verset en 2000 en
2020 la fermeture de Fessenheim était
irréversible non bien sûr on pourrait
toujours décider que tout ce qui a été
démantelé démonté peut-être reconstruit
simplement la loi française impose de
démantelés le plus vite possible selon
des prescriptions de l'Autorité de
sûreté et donc nous appliquons un
programme sous le contrôle de l'Autorité
de sûreté qui nous conduit à démanteler
le plus vite possible de manière à
retraiter les matières radioactives qui
sont sur le site donc les combustibles
ont déjà été mis dans des piscines qui
sont prévues pour cela elles sont les
les
principaux
équipements qui n'ont pas vu de
radioactivité sont bien sûr des mots
clés au fur et à mesure et on pourrait
toujours dire qu'on va reconstruire mais
pour reprendre le terme que vous avez
employé vous-même monsieur le député je
pense que ça ne serait pas dans un temps
raisonnable et par ailleurs l'idée de
faire de Fessenheim à laboratoire du
passage de 40 à 60 ans cette idée fait
l'impasse sur le fait que nous ne savons
pas aujourd'hui
ce que seront les prescriptions de la SN
pour passer de 50 à 60 ans c'est un
travail qui est en cours puisque nous
avons dépassé les 40 ans nous allons
vers les 50 ans donc il s'agit de se
préoccuper de ce qui se passera pour
cette fois-ci dépasser les 50 ans et
aller jusqu'à 60 ans mais nous ne
connaissons pas aujourd'hui les
prescriptions de la SN pour aller
au-delà de 50 ans en ce qui
pardon
non non non ce sont des critères de
sûreté monsieur le député
ce sont les critères de sûreté il y
aurait ensuite tout un tas de documents
administratifs qu'il faudrait passer
dans à travers de nombreuses
concertations et je faisais l'impasse
sur ce sujet pour toi important vous
avez raison du des permis de nous avons
besoin des autorisations nous avons
besoin pour pour fonctionner là je
parlais uniquement de reconstruction et
de passage de 50 à 60 ans qui qui est un
sujet qui aujourd'hui n'est pas
totalement
clarifié même si évidemment il fait
l'objet de travaux
ensuite vous avez parlé de politique
produits et d'abord vous avez parlé
d'inkley point
vous dire d'abord qu'il n'y a pas
d'argent prêté par le gouvernement
britannique à une cléboy puisque
justement quand je parlais industrie
économie et je parlais industrie
économie et financement la difficulté
sur une époque c'est que je dirais les
objectifs industriels sont évidemment
majeurs les réalisations les
perspectives économiques sont de bonnes
factures et par contre le financement
porte fait porter sur EDF et sur notre
partenaire chinois la totalité du
financement donc nous ne dépendons pas
de de financement du gouvernement
britannique nous
vous avez raison de dire que si nous
avions des prêts garantis par le
gouvernement britannique nous aurions
des taux de financement qui se
réveillant mais ce n'est pas le cas nous
n'avons pas de prêt garanti pour le
gouvernement britannique sur sur une clé
point
très important le prix
moyen énorme puisqu'on parle d'individu
on parle d'une échelle alors en ce qui
concerne la manière dont on calcule
effectivement les prix de revient du
nucléaire le coût du capital est
essentiel puisque le propre des
installations telles que le nucléaire
c'est que vous dépensez beaucoup pendant
la phase de construction et ensuite vous
portez devant vous une dette importante
que vous remboursez au bout de
nombreuses années avec les recettes et
que donc le le coût complet le coût
pondéré du capital entre les fonds
propres et la dette est évidemment un
élément tout à fait majeur du prix de
revient que vous calculez à la fin et
que si vous bénéficiez d'une garantie
d'un état vous empruntez et le poids de
la dette est très important vous
empruntez à des taux qui sont bien
meilleurs que si vous n'avez pas cette
garantie de l'État et que ça peut en
effet selon certains modes de calcul
fait passer pas du de 1 à 5 mais de 1 à
2 le coût complet selon vous empruntez
sur un marché ou le taux d'intéressant
cher ou bien selon que vous bénéficiez
d'une garantie de l'État ce qui fait
effondrer votre coup de
de votre taux d'intérêt enfin le coût du
le coût du capital le coupon Derrer du
capital mais en effet vu que vous
dépensez beaucoup tout de suite les
coûts d'exploitation sont relativement
mineurs même dans la durée par rapport
au coûts de construction le le le
problème de financement et tout à fait
et tout à fait clé ensuite vous avez
interrogé sur la la politique produit
sur LEPR et sur les différents EPR avec
pas mal de pas mal d'aspects que vous
avez abordé alors je vais d'abord
peut-être régler le problème de tihan si
vous le voulez bien pour vous dire que
lorsque j'ai quitté EDF il y a trois
semaines les informations publiques je
n'en ai pas vu d'autres depuis c'est que
les deux réacteurs de tasions
fonctionnent parce que j'ai cru entendre
quelqu'un dire hier qui ne fonctionnait
pas voilà les deux réacteurs de ta
chaîne fonctionnent le réacteur numéro 2
n'a pas rencontré des difficultés
particulières par contre le réacteur
numéro 1 a rencontré des difficultés
particulières qui ont conduit à une
interruption longue pour analyser les
causes de cette difficulté c'est causes
ont été analysées les conséquences de la
cause racine des difficultés rencontrées
ont été analysées également par les
autorités finlandaises françaises et
britanniques de façon à ce que quelques
adaptations qui ne sont pas
significatives puis c'est peut-être
faites sur au moment du débarrasage de
loto en Finlande de inclipoint en
Grande-Bretagne et de flamants villes en
France et puis le la partie du réacteur
qui a rencontré des difficultés va faire
l'objet d'une surveillance particulière
qui pourrait conduire plus tard à ce que
d'autres adaptations soient faites mais
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de mise en
cause du bon démarrage niddle qui lui
auto qui est quasiment démarré puis qui
s'est interrompu bon ni de Flamanville
ni un peu plus tard d'inkley point qui
serait lié au rang aux difficultés
rencontrées sur tashon et après environ
une année d'interruption le réacteur de
tihana a redémarrer et va terminer le
cycle du combustible puisque vous savez
que les réacteurs s'arrêtent pour
remplacer une partie du combustible à
période définie et donc le réacteur de
tihana en tout cas le il y a trois
semaines fonctionnait voilà je voulais
donc traiter ce sujet là ensuite la
politique produit en ce qui concerne le
Pr la politique que j'ai menée chez EDF
et de construire des EPR aussi
similaires que possible mais c'est pas
nécessairement facile parce que chaque
autorité de sûreté à sa propre vision de
la sûreté nous ne sommes pas comme dans
l'aviation civile ou quand vous avez
votre certification dans un pays vous
comme les Etats-Unis vous l'avez
automatiquement par exemple dans tous
les pays d'Europe et des facto dans tous
les pays du monde nous ne sommes pas
comme l'aviation civile chaque autorité
de sûreté est souveraine sur son pays il
y a des contacts mais quand même assez
informels entre les différentes
autorités de sûreté il y a un corps de
doctrine de la ioa basé à Vienne mais
qui donne juste des principes généraux
et donc de fait le père de Tasha n'est
pas vraiment le Pr Dolce du Loto n'est
pas vraiment le père de Flamanville
n'est pas vraiment le père d'inkley
point et ne sera pas non plus le père de
sidewell néanmoins tous ces EPR les deux
de taille Chan celui d'olive auto celui
de Flamanville ça fait 4 et les quatre
en Grande-Bretagne sont de l'EPER on va
dire de première génération avec un
certain nombre de conceptions qui sont
voisines ou
identiques et puis des mises en œuvre
qui sont un peu différentes de de site
en site qui quelquefois faut bien le
reconnaître coûte cher c'est différent
quand je suis arrivé et le projet a
prospérer depuis les ingénieurs d'EDF
avaient en tête que le Pr tel qu'il
avait été conçu et ça remonte aux années
90 au moment des accords
franco-allemand au moment où il y avait
une division nucléaire au sein de y Metz
qui a depuis été racheté par Framatome
au moment des accords franco-allemand
cet objet industriel était considéré
comme un peu compliqué et donc un EPR
dioptr optimisé a été conçu
progressivement par les ingénieurs de
déesse il est aujourd'hui disponible
pour le parc français qui va être
j'espère construire sur la base des
décisions prises par par le gouvernement
ou présenté par le présenté par le
gouvernement c'est un Neper optimiser
dont la construction est facilité avec
un certain nombre de simplification par
rapport à ce qui était devenu un petit
peu un petit peu compliqué dans le cadre
du programme franco-allemand d'origine
je me permets de revenir sur ce que je
vous avais dit l'Autorité de sûreté
nucléaire a validé toutes les options de
sûreté de cette paire de deuxième
génération toutes les options de l'EPR 2
ont été validées nous sommes en train de
faire les design détaillés qui
correspondent à ces validations mais
nous savons ce que nous avons à faire
puisque
[Musique]
la conception générale en matière de
sûreté a été accepté par la SN et donc
le travail de conception qui est à faire
il est lourd il prend du temps mais il
ne devrait pas apporter de différences
par rapport à ce qui a été d'ores et
déjà
d'ores et déjà accepté il y a peut-être
environ 18 mois ou deux ans par
l'autorité de de sûreté du clair donc
voilà ce qui concerne la politique la
politique produit de l'EPR une première
génération de père qui sont semblables
les uns aux autres mais qui ne sont pas
exactement les mêmes malheureusement et
donc ils sont 8 et puis une deuxième
génération de PR qui sont ceux que nous
espérons construire en France et puis
dans d'autres pays nous en tout cas que
des f espère construire en France et
dans d'autres pays qui
qui sont nos cibles à l'exportation et
puis je j'avais noté peut-être le
dernier sujet vous parliez des
turbines arabels donc pour vous dire que
en effet
le contrat qui lit la la maison EDF avec
Alstom devenu J et
périodiquement revue c'est vrai des
turbines rabels comme c'est vrai de la
maintenance du parc hydroélectrique
comme c'est vrai de la maintenance des
turbines à gaz puisque J est également
un fournisseur de de turbine
hydroélectrique et de turbine à gaz pour
et puis d'autres choses encore pour pour
EDF et donc périodiquement ces contrats
sont revus
a fait savoir il y a peut-être
maintenant un an et demi ou deux ans
qu'il souhaite ne souhaitait pas garder
son activité nucléaire en dehors des
États-Unis et nous a demandé à demander
à l'État français et à EDF si il était
envisageable que cette activité
industrielle soit reprise par EDF et
donc après de longs travaux de diligence
d'analyse détaillée des comptes et des
produits industriels un accord a été
signé entre J et EDF qui est aujourd'hui
soumis aux autorités de
contrôle des concentrations en Europe et
dans d'autres pays du monde et qui
devrait normalement conduire à ce que
dans les dans les dans le courant de
l'année 2023 EDF dispose d'une filiale
industrielle fabricant et assurant la
maintenance des turbines arabels voilà
ce que je voulais merci beaucoup
vous pouvez être reprendre le micro
pardon je vous en mais je pense que je
peux pas quand vous l'avez excusez-moi
est-ce que vous affirmez ou vous
confirmez les informations de la presse
comme quoi dans les mois qui ont suivi
la session de Alstom energy Adly il y a
eu une le site une grève de la
maintenance des turbines notamment
Arabel de nos centrales nucléaires et
une pression de vénérat électrique pour
revoir dans le potentiel dans des
conditions plus avantageuses pour les
Américains l'entretien de nos centrales
françaises et ces articles font état de
votre mauvaise humeur et de votre alerte
du gouvernement sur cette le site greffe
de la maintenance bien alors ça doit
vouloir dire je suis souvent de mauvaise
humeur c'est pas une bonne chose
non je n'ai pas connaissance qu'il y a
eu le moindre retard sur le parc
nucléaire qui serait lié à des
différences contractuelles entre J et
EDF par contre j'ai connaissance qu'en
effet périodiquement les contrats entre
les fournisseurs et EDF et Jean ne fait
pas exception à cela sont
examinés et renégocier
merci
je crois non je crois monsieur Tanguy
madame Bernos
oui merci
j'avais quelques questions également
vous avez dans vos propos liminaires et
évoqués le fait que nous étions et
certains d'autres personnes que nous
avons additionnées ont confirmé cela que
nous sommes en France plus
thermosensible puisque nous avons plus
d'installations électriques pour le
chauffage et donc vous l'avez qualifié
dans vos propos liminaires comme un net
avantage
je voudrais vous interroger sur le fait
que ça pourrait éventuellement
constituer au contraire une fragilité
dans la mesure où on peut s'interroger
sur l'utilisation de notre électricité
que le chauffage électrique a une plus
faible efficacité énergétique et que la
chaleur renouvelable existe et
et nécessaire à être développé c'est une
première question de dire est-ce que ce
n'est pas une fragilité française que
d'avoir beaucoup de son parc de
chauffage en électricité sur la question
des énergies renouvelables on comprend
bien que on a eu un retard en France sur
le développement des énergies
renouvelables nous avons interrogé votre
prédécesseur monsieur Proglio qui tenait
à propos à peu près les mêmes propos que
vous avez tenus sur les énergies
renouvelables vous avez dit on n'a pas
les moyens on n'avait pas les moyens à
EDF financiers de le faire est-ce que
vous confirmez donc simplement que dans
la stratégie d'EDF vous avez privilégié
des moyens financiers et techniques sur
le nucléaire au détriment des énergies
renouvelables c'est cette précision que
je souhaitais avoir je voulais revenir
même si ça a été évoqué par d'autres
orateurs
les le fameux projet de inclipoints
monsieur le Président de la Commission
vous a interrogé sur la décision du
Conseil administration d'EDF en 2016
après effectivement la démission du
directeur financier monsieur pickman qui
déclare je cite ne pas pouvoir
cautionner une décision susceptible avec
ce projet d'amener EDF dans une
situation proche de celle d'Areva il y a
aussi des administrateurs qui iront
jusqu'à saisir la justice pour stopper
le lancement du projet considérant que
vous ne leur avez pas fourni des
éléments nécessaires et les informations
vont votre possession pour prendre une
décision éclairée lors de ce conseil
d'administration trois ont d'ailleurs
été reconnus des personnes participant à
ce conseil d'administration en conflit
d'intérêt au moment de ce vote
ma question est donc assez simple c'est
il y a eu des recours en justice qui ont
été
portés par des personnes qui faisaient
partie du conseil d'administration sur
le fait qu'il y aurait eu qu'il n'avait
pas eu toutes les informations pour
prendre un bot et une décision éclairée
à ce conseil d'administration de juillet
2016 et dans le rendu du des tribunaux
il y a manifestement trois personnes qui
participaient au conseil
d'administration qui semblait être en
conflit d'un terrain en tout cas c'est
ce que la justice a indiqué
ma question est donc qu'est-ce qui a pu
motiver on voit quand même qu'il y a eu
pas mal de tension y compris au sein
d'EDF ce passage en force
au sujet du projet de inkipoint sur la
question de l'EPR et vous avez évoqué et
vous l'avez réitéré ici les difficultés
en matière de compétence ou manque de
compétences par rapport
au désastre où on peut le qualifier
comme on veut ou dérapage sur le père de
Flamanville aussi bien en termes de
coûts
je cite monsieur Proglio que nous avons
auditionné hier qui nous a dit la chose
suivante le père est un enjeu trop
compliqué quasi un constructible on
envoie aujourd'hui des difficultés les
grands patrons du nucléaire d'EDF
l'avait anticipé c'était le seul outil
qui a été disponible dans notre univers
j'avais testé en étant administrateur
indépendant contre les avenants au
contrat de construction de l'entreprise
de construction on était au 15ème
avenant il a ensuite il expliqué qu'elle
allait sur place pour vérifier et que
l'entreprise lui dit tu sais si je ne
vais pas là dedans j'arrête les travaux
c'est des citations non parce que je ne
peux pas m'en sortir j'ai déjà perdu 250
millions donc j'arrête et il explique et
donc vous passez du 17e 18e 19e 20e
avenant c'est une vie sans fin j'ai eu
la faiblesse d'annoncée pour 2014 la
connexion au réseau parce que mes
ingénieurs m'avaient dit écoutez chef
vous pouvez annoncer 2000 année 2012 ça
devrait coller quoi j'ai pris deux ans
de marge mais bon toujours pas connecté
en 2012 donc non il y a un vrai problème
de l'EPR est-ce que c'est pas plutôt une
un souci de cet ordre là de cette lancée
dans une aventure qui n'était
manifestement pas maîtrisée et qu'on ne
savait pas faire et que on poursuit dans
cette fuite en avant la dernière
question que je voulais vous poser
c'était concerne les problèmes de
qualité traçabilité et de surveillance
dans l'usine italienne de fabrication
des pièces de remplacement pour la
corrosion
l'ASN a récemment mené une inspection
dans l'usine textubie à potenzano en
Italie ou EDF sous traite la fabrication
des pièces de remplacement pour les
circuits affectés par la cohésion sous
contrainte dans son rapport d'inspection
qui date du 7 novembre dernier il relève
un sérieux problème de qualité un
manquement de traçabilité de
surveillance et en août la SN
son à l'identique avec les anciennes
donc faute de retour d'expérience
incriminant les matériaux les procédés
de fabrication en tant que fabricant
réglementaire vous êtes chargé du
contrôle de la sous-traitance de ces
pièces que pouvez-vous nous dire des
conditions qui règnent sur les sites de
fabrication de cette usine au regard des
difficultés que représente aujourd'hui
la corrosion sous contrainte de la
filière comment se fait-il que la SN
puisse aujourd'hui constater de tels
manquements est-ce que vous avez pris
des mesures suite aux demandes formulées
par la SN peut-on garantir que les
pièces de remplacement ne seront pas
affectées par la corrosion sous
contrainte il me semble que là c'est
d'une importance aussi actuelle par
rapport à la sécurisation
d'approvisionnement énergétique français
et aussi pourquoi sous-traitez-vous
cette fabrication essentielle pour la
sécurité de nos centrales en Italie
merci Monsieur Davy merci beaucoup de
questions et beaucoup d'informations qui
ont des sources que j'ignore
l'intervosensibilité je crois que je
crois que le chauffage électrique pour
tous ceux qui sont attentifs à la
décarbonation est évidemment un atout
majeur de notre de notre pays vous avez
parlé de chaleur renouvelable oui c'est
très bien mais quels sont les quels sont
les perspectives dans ce dans ce domaine
puisque les volumes de chaleur
renouvelables sont extrêmement
modestes et on aimerait bien évidemment
que l'économie circulaire fonctionne un
peu mieux mais on sait bien que les
perspectives de chaleur renouvelables je
ne parle pas de de je ne parle pas de à
partir de gaz et de charbon chère Madame
pour les les réseaux pour les réseaux
urbains comme on le sait la plupart des
réseaux urbains dans le monde utilisent
de façon très majoritaire du gaz et du
charbon donc ce n'est pas dans cette
ce n'est pas dans cette perspective que
que que
le DF quand je le dirigeais se situait
nous essayons en effet de répondre aux
demandes de l'ADEME qui était de limiter
les l'utilisation de combustibles
fossile mais chacun voyait bien
le les contraintes qui pouvaient
s'exercer en particulier sur la biomasse
ou sur la récupération de chaleur issue
de déchets et donc
avec la ressource qui est disponible il
n'y a pas de doute qu'il faut beaucoup
de chauffage électrique et nous avons
quand je dirigeais EDF militait avec
succès pour enfin mettre fin à cette
réglementation qui avait été mise en
place je crois dans les années 2012 qui
donnait une priorité au chauffage au gaz
et qui donc
détruisait une grande partie des
équilibres
de l'écosensibilité de la planète à
cause du gaz naturel donc vous dites est
un avantage ou une fragilité je crois
que c'est clairement un avantage c'est
ce que j'ai dit de mon dans mon propos
introductif que nous ayons la
possibilité
d'utiliser beaucoup d'électricité des
cartonnées pour nous chauffer nous
pourrions sûrement l'optimiser encore
davantage je j'ai vu des chiffres
récemment qui montraient qu'une très
très grande majorité des bâtiments
évidemment les logements individuels
mais aussi des bâtiments collectifs ne
disposent pas de système d'optimisation
de de
la manière dont ils sont chauffés et
donc je crois qu'il y a plus à
rechercher aujourd'hui du côté de
l'efficacité énergétique dans les dans
les bâtiments et ce sont des dossiers
que les équipes d'EDF travaillent
étroitement avec la profession du
bâtiment
ENR oui j'ai dit en effet que j'aurais
bien aimé disposer de plus d'argent pour
faire des des honers mais je crois qu'il
faut distinguer ce qui relève de la
France et ce qui relève des autres pays
dans nous ne pouvons pas être
compétitifs dans le domaine des ENR si
nous ne sommes pas présents hors de
France
Pourquoi et bien parce que la France
représente moins de 1% de ce qui est de
ce qui se construit chaque année en
matière d'éolien et de solaire et que
l'objectif d'EDF étant de disposer de
30% de parts de marché en France ça
voudrait dire que nous serions
compétitifs avec une part de marché
aussi faible c'est évidemment impossible
et donc j'aurais bien aimé que nous
puissions être encore plus compétitif en
ayant encore plus de moyens pour faire
des ENR en dehors de en dehors de France
en France je crois que nous avons
disposé des moyens nécessaires à
répondre aux appels d'offres je rappelle
que sur l'éolien en mer qui est
peut-être la technologie la plus
prometteuse EDF a gagné 4
des 7 appels d'offres qui ont été
lancés ou attribué d'ailleurs parce
qu'il y en a un huitième qui a été lancé
mais pas attribué des quatre des sept
appels d'offres d'éolien maritime qui
ont été attribués en France qui ont été
pour EDF donc nous avons essayé de
mettre un maximum des ressources que
nous avions à la fois les ressources
humaines et les moyens financiers pour
faire des ENR en France et nous avons en
effet souffert de ne pas pouvoir en
faire davantage à l'étranger ce qui nous
aurait rendu encore plus compétitifs y
a-t-il eu un arbitrage entre les les
constructions nucléaires et les EnR je
répondrai oui et non parce que lorsqu'il
s'agit de maintenir le parc nucléaire
existant ou de terminer le chantier de
Flamanville on ne peut pas vraiment
parler d'arbitrage maintenant il est
clair que la décision je vais y revenir
qui a été prise sur une clé point est
une décision de politique qui a été
prise par le conseil d'administration
d'EDF et qui est une décision de
politique industrielle de politique
énergétique
et qui je crois correspond au fait que
les majorités qui ont été élus par le
peuple en France au fil du temps ont
toute confirmé la nécessité de
poursuivre le nucléaire et de ce point
de vue là donc je reviens
inclipoint était à mes yeux une une
démonstration très claire que nous
n'étions pas seuls nous les français
mais nous avions il y avait d'autres
pays d'Europe pas seulement en Europe de
l'Est mais aussi à proximité ça a été
confirmé depuis avec Saez well d'autres
pays très proches comme la
Grande-Bretagne était prêt à s'associer
au projet industriels nucléaires en
France ensuite j'ai pas bien compris ce
que vous aviez dit sur une clé point en
matière de passage en force puisque
conseil d'administration qui vote à la
majorité je ne vois pas ce qui vous
amène à dire que c'est un passage en
force un directeur financier qui
démissionne parce qu'il a trouvé à vrai
dire 15 jours après il était dans une
autre banque il est dans une banque
alors bon chacun peut voir si la
démissionné parce qu'il n'était pas
d'accord parce qu'il avait trouvé un
meilleur travail bon en tout cas
il a dit ce qu'il voulait dire il s'est
exprimé d'ailleurs ici même ensuite en
ce qui concerne les conflits d'intérêt
moi j'en ai pas la trace donc j'aimerais
que vous me trouviez la décision de
justice pas l'article d'un journal s'il
vous plaît la décision de justice qui
qui parce que s'il y a une décision de
justice qui dit qu'il y a un conflit
d'intérêt il y a une décision de justice
qui annule la décision du Conseil
puisque s'il y a conflit d'intérêt
automatiquement la justice annule la
décision du conseil donc je serais
intéressé à savoir quelle est la
décision de justice à laquelle vous vous
référez
la référence la décision de justice
madame
donc c'est une décision de justice qui
date de février 2017 du tribunal de
commerce de Paris je cite qu'il est
manifeste qu'au vu des éléments du
dossier que trois animistrateurs étaient
également administrateurs de société
susceptibles de bénéficier de façon
certaine ou potentielle des retombées
industriels et commerciales du projet
inclipoint exceptionnelle tant par sa
taille que par sa renommée mondiale et
qu'un si ces trois administrateurs
avaient un intérêt de nature à influer
ou à paraître influé sur leur
impersalité
et la dernière citation c'est que leur
citation était caractéristique d'une
situation de conflit d'intérêt donc sur
la base de cette analyse madame la
députée le tribunal de commerce n'a pas
annulé alors qu'il en a le pouvoir la
décision du Conseil d'Administration
cité cette décision de justice puisque
manifestement il y avait la démission
d'un directeur financier et puis des
recours juridiques par rapport à
l'influence qui avait eu et de pas avoir
les bonnes informations pour décider de
s'engager ou pas dans le projet
inkipoint au conseil d'administration de
juillet 2016 il me semblait que ces
éléments étaient de nature normale dans
le cadre de cette commission d'enquête
de vous interroger sur ces faits là
puisque vous êtes ici aussi sincèrement
sous cette audition très bien donc je
vous confirme sincèrement que la
décision du Conseil d'Administration
d'EDF n'a pas été annulé au motif d'un
quelconque conflit d'intérêt d'un
administrateur madame le député
sur le Pr finalement votre question et
je lave je vous rejoindrai est-ce qu'on
est parti trop tôt
oui je crois que le rapport folle montre
bien que le lancement des travaux de
l'eperge je vous invite à le relire si
ou à le lire il fait 30 pages il est il
est accessible facilement le rapport
Falls dit bien que la construction du
chantier a démarré alors que la
conception détaillée n'avait pas été
approuvée et que les plans d'exécution
n'était qu'à peine disponible évidemment
tous les plans d'exécution ne sont
jamais disponibles au moment du
lancement d'un chantier mais là il y en
avait pratiquement pas et que donc on a
on a été
pénaliser le chantier a été pénalisé par
le fait que le la décision de lancer le
chantier aurait dû être prise avec
davantage d'études disponibles je dirais
aussi que sur le chantier de flamant
ville le des modifications ont été
apportées par l'Autorité de sûreté aux
règles de gestion des appareils sous
pression qui ont évidemment induits des
changements et des retards sujets sur
lequel le rapport de Jean-Martin folle
c'est également assez disaire enfin vous
vous référez à une
la document de la SN que je ne connais
pas qui parlerait de problèmes de
qualité d'acier fabriqué en Italie pour
réparer les tuyaux de corrosion sous
contrainte donc là madame la députée je
ne connais pas le document de la SN dont
vous parlez vous avez dit qu'il est du
mois de novembre et avant de quitter mes
fonctions je n'en ai pas eu connaissance
je sais qu'en effet deux sociétés
italiennes ont été en mesure de
fabriquer assez rapidement des les
aciers dont on a besoin je vous dirai
simplement que le problème n'est pas
tant la qualité des aciers que la
qualité des soudures et que toutes les
informations qui me sont remontées c'est
que les soudures de réparation qui ont
été faites sur les réacteurs qui sont
atteints par la corrosion sous
contrainte que c'est soudures sont
faites avec la qualité nécessaire et que
tous les réacteurs qui ont été
redémarrés l'ont été après évidemment
une approbation par la SN de la qualité
de 6 soudure telle qu'elle est mesurée
donc moi je n'ai pas connaissance d'un
document de la SN sur l'acier lui-même
l'inspection de la SN qui a été menée
dans l'usine italienne c'est dates du 18
octobre 2022 peut-être que c'était parce
que vous étiez enfin de mandat mais en
tout cas normalement il me semble que le
directeur général d'EDF aurait dû avoir
connaissance puisque ce rapport a été
fait suite à cette inspection menée et
qui incriminait non seulement qui posait
la question sur la qualité des matériaux
ou les procédés de fabrication et c'est
dans ce sens là que cette inspection a
été menée et donc moi ça m'inquiète que
vous n'ayez pas ou ne soyez pas au
courant de ces rapports de l'ASN merci
je enfin si vous voulez compléter mais
je confirme que je n'ai pas été informé
de d'une quelconque
analyse de la nature dont madame la
députée parle et d'ailleurs on recevra
la SN mais on prend le demander à la SN
date d'inspection et remise de rapport
c'est c'est rarement en concomitant d'un
point de vue
calendaire merci beaucoup Monsieur Lévy
pour votre disponibilité pour les
réponses précises
et les interrogations que vous avez
partagées avec nous
je pense que tout ça contribue
progressivement de comprendre le paysage
décisionnel français en matière
d'énergie et les relations que
qu'entretiennent les les différents
acteurs je pense aussi que ce soir nous
avons fait honneur à la représentation
nationale en poursuivant nos travaux
malgré les événements populaires qui
préoccupent
je pense ce soir une majorité de nos
compatriotes je vous souhaite à toutes
et à tous une belle soirée